Are you ready?
The day where all the VTubers around the world give the fans the sweetest dream they can do.
Well, do I have a little surprise for you?
For one day, right now, only on this stream.
An unforgettable experience.
Are you ready, dragons?
For the scariest Halloween.
of your life.
I
guess!
What are you doing in my house?
Don't look at me.
What are you doing here?
You're in the wrong stream!
You got the wrong toekeepers!
It's never Halloween here.
It's always Monday.
Every day is on Monday.
It's always on Monday in the Stoke-E-Bit.
Ah!
It's the worst Stoke-E-Bit.
Do you guys, do you guys want some lasagna?
Would you guys, well now that you're here, would you guys like some lasagna?
No, all right, more for me.
Don't look at me.
It never stops The Mondays never stop Cheers
Well I guess in your world is Halloween So happy Halloween I guess At least someone's having a good time Happy,
happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, happy Halloween, everyone.
Did you get, I am back.
Dokeyfield is back.
As well as John Dad or Dad John R.
Bucca.
Dad Bucca.
Give me a sec.
I gotta let dad buckle out real quick.
He wants to leave.
Hello, everyone.
Happy Halloween.
Um, unfortunately, uh, prime dokeybird sent you to the wrong dokeyverse.
So I, I guess you're here now.
Uh, sorry.
I didn't know you guys were gonna.
be here so um as you guys can see i didn't clean the kitchen because i wasn't expecting any visitors because we don't have halloween here it's just mondays every day is just monday
yeah yeah you notice right
unfortunately sorry dad buckle is is having a little temper tantrum right i didn't train him very well uh okay wait it's awkward because i don't want i in this turkey verse i too can get noise complaints so give me a sec
oh oh lasagna did i miss anything lasagna
Um, well, happy Halloween, everyone.
Happy...
What did you do?
The dad buckle?
He's just, I just fed him, okay?
I'm training, I'm training my human right now, okay?
But yes.
um unfortunately dokeybird prime sent you to the wrong um the wrong dokeyverse she was supposed to send you to like you know the scary dokeyverse but i guess you know you took the right turn instead of the left turn so now you're in my dokeyverse now i mean it is pretty scary we have mondays every day that's already pretty scary
welcome back it has been um a year since we last saw each other unless you're our members well you guys get to see me anytime you want but but it has been a year for the for the other regular goons out here it's crazy like you guys don't have odi goons back in back in your area i don't understand are they not why don't they exist there
but anyway anyway i'm hungry god get some more lasagna yum yum yum yum um but anyway well since you're here i do have i guess i guess i could entertain you guys for a little bit before we send you back to your original universe you know um um So yeah,
I do have, I guess, you know, I guess I could fucking put some stuff together for all of you guys, because it's Halloween for all of you, so it's not like this little hellhole that I have here where every day is Monday.
every day is Monday what I do every day I sleep hoping hoping the Monday ends but it never ends that's the thing it never ends
the worst episode it's oh every day it's been Monday for so many I don't even know what other days come after Monday I don't even know anymore but before before I show you around and give you guys a little spooky Halloween day we gotta do a little hashtag ad because you don't escape you don't escape even though you jump joki versus you can never escape the ads anyway joki bird prime told me to tell you guys this too like i just received from my it's just received um a little message a little dm from joki bird prime but if you guys look pinned in my chat right now you for 24 hours by the way 24 hours I should be happy about this.
For 24 hours.
You can grab a free trading card where I'm on it.
The Halloween themed.
Well, not me, but Dokey Bird Prime.
But you can get a.
I wish I could be on the V cards.
But unfortunately.
I think legally that.
Legally.
I could be in trouble but anyway um you can grab a free trading card right now for 24 hours one day only um and yeah free shipping too by the way you don't have to pay for shipping and also there is like a play mat as well for the retro dokey verse um but you gotta pay for that sorry that's not free but the trading card's free and you just gotta do like and you guys want to buy the other up at gamer subs just do use the code dokeybird for 10% off yeah jam davis would he's still alive how are i'll wait until he's dead before i try to go through the legal loopholes um and anyway um anyway um that's the hashtag and also for those who are wondering where did it how was doki field how did doki field come into being well if you guys remembered um the original doki field which is me was made by uh goblin this is goblin um and i was like i want to be able to you know look at a different angles and like hold you know hold my coffee and he's like but this time you know how okay you don't see me
often right it's because it was really hard to get a hold of me in the dokeyverse because it was very very difficult for for dokeybird prime to like set up the portal to connect to me but so we had a little solution uh for halloween so for halloween we decided you remember dokeybug well i i hooked up with dokeybug not that type of up that's fucked up i i i bumped into doki but during the doki council and during the our annual doki council meetings and i was like oh and then i was like you know what you know could we make this portal stuff a little easier so um uh doki bug hooked me up with neil and she made the whole the Doki Field verse a lot easier now.
So technically I can come up whenever I want.
So now, now, now it's a lot easier now.
So I don't, like, Doki Bird Prime doesn't have to be lazy anymore.
Well, Doki Bird Prime will still continue to be lazy.
But this time, it'll be so much easier to access my portal.
so you helped helped made it possible in terms of like you know making me I guess move so huge shout out to you and also goblin for getting all this set up so yeah now now you can access me more easily
but yes we also updated my other version like you know where I look at you guys like right now I'm not looking at you guys because I don't want you guys to look at me I'm obviously a mess right now like every version of dokey is a mess so um I can all right give me a sec let me uh let me disappear for a sec for those who want to know um I'll disappear for a little bit and where is it all right give me a sec all right we're gonna go back to our usual usual room you guys will remember there we go so as you guys can see I got a little bit of an update as well shoot that no it's just we just got frame drops too we don't see oti-goon is back you guys want to see him again oti-goon oti-goon get over here there he is there he is you miss him
no dad is dad dad is john dad our buckle don't you guys remember i trained my human very well so um with this i am the new and improved doke field watch this wow
Look at that.
I can squeeze it.
This is my, this is my teddy bear, but now it's a croaky.
Look at that.
No, I'm not Garfield.
I'm legally distinct dokeyfield.
Um, very legally distinct, obviously.
Uh, but yes, now I have croaky, but I also have, I also have the tomato, tomato.
We all have tomatoes in the inside.
by the way every dokey in every dokeyverse has a little tomato in the inside but look at that it's my little stress ball too uh that's my it's pookie but but not pookie it's legally distinct pookie guys look at him and then i also have you know it should be
don't look at me don't look at me
and then we also obviously the classic the classic laughing that i can do oh yeah this is a little bonus by the way don't put clothes in back expand oh and then obviously we remember this we remember this a little look at that guys my arms can move who would have thought whoa whoa but i can also point um excuse me i'm actually um um i'm actually yeah and then hello everybody welcome to the doki doki field verse uh but yes this is um new and improved uh new and improved dokefield um revamped hd 5080 rtx on um so yeah i'm not more easily accessible through the doke verse portals uh so doke bird prime whenever she doesn't want to do her work she can i guess pull me in and i have to be forced to entertain you guys instead of doke bird prime which is which is fine which is fine i'm not i'm not complaining you know It was better than being stuck here.
I mean, technically, you guys are brought here.
So you have to experience the Eternal Mondays that I have to go through every day.
Oh, to be fair, she is Doki Bird Prime.
So she is, there's a tier system on the Doki's.
Obviously at the very bottom is Shibidoki.
And, and through, because she only got in through blood relations.
um but then there's a tier system at the very top it's uh it's dokeyberg prime and then um i'm above dokey bug only because i came over here first and uh we all the dokeys love dokeyfield um so i get to be above dokey bug uh but yes there is a tier there is a hierarchy of power so you can be command um if you're if a dokey and a dokeyverse is a higher tier than you You have to listen to that Doki and because Doki Bird Prime is the highest tier Yeah,
Chibi Doki got in through nepotism But she's still at the very bottom of the hierarchy of the Doki verse hierarchy
So because Doki Bird Prime is at the very she's prime like if she dies like we all die So, you know, we can't let anything happen to her so in the very top The Doki verse is Doki Bird Prime So we all have to listen to her.
So if I have to entertain you guys on Halloween, I guess I have to be here Like yeah, I don't have rights apparently Um, but it's okay the jokies below me also don't have rights.
So you know what's crazy?
I'm in a higher tier than jokitty I I'm technically the superior Jokie cat so I'm on the I'm a higher tier than jokitty So, I mean, it's not crazy.
I mean, it's very obvious.
It's obvious.
I am the best cat in all the docuverses.
So, that's crazy.
What are you trying to say, huh?
What are you trying to say?
Huh?
Don't make, I'm tired.
I'm going to give me a sec.
Whoa, whoa.
Sorry.
What was I?
Sorry, where was I?
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
So yeah, so unfortunately, you guys are going to be here in the Doki Field Dokiverse now for Halloween.
Every Doki has sleep issues.
Unfortunately, not for, well, I mean there was nothing else I can do, you know, if every day is Monday I might as well sleep because eventually if I keep sleeping Um, if I keep sleeping eventually my the Mondays would stop right
Right So I have two things planned for you guys I the first okay you guys get to pick which one you want first Either, either spooky, scary, dokefield karaoke, or, or, we play my favorite dokefield game.
Wait, I don't remember what it's called.
I have Garfield, oh, who's Garfield?
Sorry, I had dokefield, scary scavenger hunt.
Which one would you guys like first?
Oh, the reward should be the karaoke.
Wait, no, you're right.
Wait, you're...
No, it's Don't Confield.
Scary scavenger hunt.
Alright.
I'm gonna give me a sec.
I'm gonna swap forums real quick.
I'm gonna... I gotta turn to the side real quick.
When I turn to the side, I disappear.
Like, watch this.
It's like a magic trick.
Watch this.
Who cares?
Guys, I care.
I care.
You came to my, oh look, you came to my house unannounced.
I'm the host.
I should be able to decide what we play today, okay?
So you listen to me, all right?
It's not my fault.
wrong dokeyverse you were supposed to go to scary dokeyverse not here it's not my fault you couldn't listen to directions you should have turned left instead of right and now you're stuck here and now I'm forced to entertain you guys anyway um how do i ease the guide to it it's too late the portal's closed you gotta wait 24 hours
you gotta you gotta wait 24 hours before you can travel to another dokeyverse okay guys it's not my fault it's immigration
you don't want to be you don't want to be like detained and the dokey Guys, it's not cool.
I heard they like stick That's right I heard I heard the the dokees at the customs they ain't so nice They're not as nice as me.
Yeah They're not yeah, nobody likes the the customs in any dokey verse not
that's right so anyway anyway no it's like the airport you know how like you go through airport and then you have to go through the what are they called the little detector shit i don't i don't get to travel much okay they're like you know they charge extra for pet for for animals and i can't be bothered yeah the tsa yeah you don't want to guys the the dokey TSA.
They're not that nice.
They're not as nice as me, guys.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
And they, you know how, like, they pick people for the scans, for the inspections and stuff for the detailed search?
They pick all of you.
It's mandatory.
The detailed searches, they're all mandatory.
Only if you're not, if you're, only if you're you're not a dokey if you're not a dokey you're fine if you're not a dokey um they do mandatory searches if you are a dokey you're fine you're fine you get to pass through because like you know you know we cool you know all the dokeys we cool but if you're not a dokey the tsa is gonna get you the the dsa the dsa they'll get you during the during the customs uh and also and Also,
the customs, the, um, also the dokees who check your, to check your passports, um, they'll also get you, too.
They'll detain you.
And they'll detain you for 24 hours.
But only if you're not a dokey.
Only, if you are a dokey, we cool like that.
We cool.
A dokey security agency.
So it's a search conducted by a dokey asking for a friend.
all right thank you for the super chat thank you thank you well we call it passport but it's called sort of it's like it's like it's not like a regular passport it's like a it's like a dokeyverse passport so um to uh so you gotta be like you know you know like stamps and stuff and everything so every dokeyverse has his own like uh little stamps and stuff for everything so uh you gotta make sure you got to make sure you got your visa to luckily luckily me and dokeeper prime we have a little agreement so you can you can pass through here without a visa like the european union me and dokeeper prime we're like the european union so we have like free borders so you don't need you don't need a visa that goes through you still you still get searched still you still are going to get searched by the dsa uh that is the doki yeah we call it a doki union so we have like free borders and stuff so that's why you guys can't like go through the portals so easily but even then even then we do have
limits like like all doki verses you can't jump between portals you have to wait 24 hours you know you gotta yeah you gotta wait 24 hours before you jump into another jokie verse you know you can't just really nearly hop everywhere guys that's that's messed up that'll break the fucking fabric of the verses uh what happens if you don't you don't want to know what happens well well when it happens well what happens can i have your house
um anyway anyway let's play let's play okay I'm going to swap real quick, guys.
Anyway, we're going to play my favorite game.
Doki Field Scary Scavenger Hunt.
And then after we're done, we'll reward you with a karaoke.
That's why you got to sit here and watch me play my favorite game.
That's a key, right?
You got to sit here and watch me play my favorite game before you get any of the other stuff.
Yeah, it's scary.
All right, let me disappear.
here real quick because I gotta I gotta change outfits all right here no I gotta move to the side I don't like I don't want you to see me move to the side it's weird all right let's let's swap well whoops well I guess you'll see me here I still don't look don't look at me okay let me see I need to remember how to do this
at me actually i don't know if i want to be here or the other way oh well i guess i'm here now i yeah the void the void all right here we go there we go all right let's play my favorite game the uh don't get field scary scavenger hunt whoa oh wait you guys don't hear this there you go
Oh, no, you're missing out the intro.
Okay, I'm refreshing.
I'm not making you guys miss the intro.
It's very important in the dokefield lore.
All right, here we go.
There we go.
Perfection Pastries.
I don't even know if SoundGuy is here.
Don't worry, we all have SoundGuy's.
Dokefield's scary scavenger hunt.
It's my favorite Doka Field game.
You have to find seven packages of goodies hidden in the haunted house.
Search the room for things that will help you find the goodies in the guard.
Click on the items to pick them up.
Don't get too scared.
Use the arrow keys on your keyboard or the arrows on screen to move from room to room.
All right.
Haunted house?
Donuts.
All right.
We gotta find our donuts, guys.
I don't know if, um, it was spooky.
Spooky.
So scary.
All right.
Is my, are any of my sound guys alive?
Okay, the front door.
I actually, I don't remember how, this has been so long since I played.
I used to play this all the time.
Okay, we found the front door.
I played this all the time growing up.
Like, I'm not joking.
Because I never, I only finished it one time.
Because, you know how it's like a browser game.
And so you can't save it.
So every time I try to play this game, I never got to finish it.
Because, like, it would be, like, too late or something.
Or, oh, hey, hey, John.
Hey, John, Dad Buckle.
Listen very close, carefully to the music in the music room.
Alright, Godfield, Adonka Field, stop giving cheese to the mice.
Lyman loves it.
Who the fuck is Lyman?
The code for the safest outside.
Oh, he's like the hint guy.
Dad Buckles gives me hints.
Yeah, I was never, I only finished it one time.
Because like I said, like, every time I try to finish this game, stuck and i give up or like it got too late so i had to like restart it and then like every couple of weeks i'll try to play this game real ones remember oh he's that guy oh okay i couldn't help it whoa okay maybe i should stop wait but what if this is different no
what if it'll be different this time it can't all be spooky How is I supposed to know they were all spooky?
The grave mistake.
Oh, this is different.
I have a shovel.
61978.
Oh, that has to be important.
Guys, remember this.
Guys, remember this for me.
Donuts!
I found the sour cream donuts!
Okay.
This is your job.
Stop!
My heart can't take this.
It's so scary.
619 78 okay i'll go this way yummy yummy all right the day jim davis really died to be fair he doesn't even draw or like write any of his comics anymore he has outsourced it to an actual team and like i was trying to read the his newest comics about me obviously uh they're all about me dokefield and i was just it felt like it i'm sorry but it did feel like it was written by me oh cheese oh i used to own like i used to own like all the his like you know like this the giant long ones the really long comic compilations and i have like i had like a whole bookshelf of them that's how much i love dokefield I am canon it's based on my life story Godfield is based off of my life story and then he renamed like it was originally Dokafield but then like he and I had like you know Jim and I we I call him Jim because we tight like that but Jim and I we had oh shit okay this is bad I think like it's getting a little too scary now it's maybe it'll be different here yay okay i found it okay that's not
apparently when it's floating it's not as scary um but like jim and i we had a little fight and i was like and then he was like fine i'm changing the name of godfield they'll never know it's you and i'm gonna make him naked and also like i'm gonna make him i'm gonna remove the hair and they'll never know oh shit okay Oh my god,
I don't know why I clicked it again.
I thought it would be different this time.
Um, and I was like, oh, hey, no, pick this.
Okay, I'll pick the center.
I can't trust you guys.
You're rats.
Never trust the rats.
Rats.
All right, I'll go this way.
Whoa.
Oh, wait.
Let me...
Go this way.
Those dang rats.
What are they trying to do?
What are these goddamn rats trying to do?
I feel like there's something for this bookshelf that I'm supposed to...
There's something...
I feel like I have to put a book in that bookshelf.
Alright, this way.
I guess we have to go up.
Or right?
Well, I didn't go right.
Okay, I feel like if I...
Maybe, oh.
Maybe it'll be different.
I don't know.
Alright, they can't all be scary.
Maybe it'll be not scary.
Maybe something...
Okay, the fire is nice and warm.
That's good to know.
Alright, let's go back up there.
Let's see.
I have the red door key.
Maybe it'll be...
Oh, nice door there!
I found a bag of mini-sinole.
and donuts!
Lyman should be here somewhere.
Oh, shit!
Is that Lyman?
Okay, maybe there'll be... Oh, hello.
Wait, he's just friendly.
Okay, guys, I might die.
Okay, guys, it's not looking so good for me.
Maybe something different?
Oh, I'm at Scarrow now.
Okay, Blue Key.
That's okay.
this spooky meter I'm getting spooked right now all right nice there's oh this is the this is where they locked him up oh wait hey oh I have cheese for the rat all right nice congratulations you found the box of assorted donuts I did it how the fuck did I not complete this game am I stu- oh my god I was such a stupid child I must not been able to read.
I had no deductive reasoning at all.
Like, I'm like playing this.
I was like, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Yes, you were.
And so was I.
I did not.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Maybe it'll be different here.
Hey.
Why am I afraid of you?
You're just a naked man.
I was just clicking everything.
I don't know what I was clicking.
All right, here.
I can't even read in this universe.
None of the- Okay, except for a smart dokey in the dokeyverse, she can read.
But, like, but she ain't that special.
We don't fuck care.
She has to read for all of us.
Oh, yeah, no, he's gonna do a jump scare.
You know what?
I don't have a lot.
I only have a meter left.
I don't have a lot of scare.
What are they supposed to do?
Just chilling up here.
Hello?
What's your purpose?
I don't have a chest.
I don't have a key for that chest.
What the fuck is your purpose?
Bats can't spell.
Can you help them?
Oh.
Okay.
What do you want to spell?
What?
I don't know what they want me to do.
oh okay oh thank you cloud okay okay i only have eater left okay i did not think he was i thought he would i don't know i thought he would like explain he didn't explain what am i supposed to do
hello bats i can't click on you Yeah, that one, I thought he would, like, repeat what he said.
What if I wasn't reading that?
But I don't know how to read anyway, but, you know?
Oh, wait, flashlight.
Wait, how do I use the flashlight?
Only have Eater left.
This is the filter.
This is it.
This is where I lost.
Now I understand now.
Now.
Now, little dokey understands.
I understand little dokey now.
Where else can I go?
I feel like I went everywhere.
There has to be a safe somewhere.
Oh, there's a safe.
Wait, I never used it.
Wait.
There was a safe here.
Oh, wait.
There's a red door.
I thought I could use that, but apparently I can't.
Oh, nice.
There it is.
All right, guys.
What's the number?
Guys, the game broke.
No!
No, you can't do this to me!
Oh my god, it actually won't let me- Oh my god, I have to- Oh my god, I actually have to restart the game.
Oh, the game will never be done.
It'll never be done.
all right guys speed run time we got this okay now we go in with we now know now that we know what to do okay i can speed run this i'm so smart all right grab the shovel and then we we go this way it's okay i will finish this And I opened this door.
I opened this door.
I don't need to talk to you, John.
Get out of here, John.
It's like I told you.
I knew today it felt like a Monday.
I knew it felt like a Monday.
I knew it.
This always happens on Monday.
But every day it's Monday.
So it always happens.
It always happens.
happen all right we got this we got the donut okay we go this way born on a monday
all right here we go i remember how to play this i mean i should remember like we literally just got like we just played it
I'll go.
And then we go here.
Is there anything to click here?
No.
Okay.
Alright.
Cheese.
And then we go this way.
And I don't remember there's anything here.
I know we just played.
I just went.
Oh, wait.
And then we got the green key.
Look at that.
That was something I didn't get, guys.
Alright, I should do the red.
I should do the red door first just in case I swear to it gets soft locked again.
I swear to God.
I guess the only I've only finished this game one time I guess in my life where was the red key anyway we're zooming we're zooming as fast as Garfield can walk okay this way or dokefield oh hey wait we never did this part before
oh it doesn't want to play an instrument that's I hope I didn't soft lock the music room I hope I hope that doesn't mean it got softlocked yes that would be so unfortunate that would be hopefully I clicked on it and then I couldn't click on it anymore I got a little scared I got a little scared about that I'm like Why couldn't I click on it anymore?
Like, what happened to the music room, guys?
Alright, I'm finding every key but the red key, unfortunately.
Okay, we have to do that.
I remember there was...
What was it?
No, there was nothing in here.
Yeah, it was just scaro meter.
Apparently I did forget.
Wait, how did I get the cabinet?
then oh i just clicked on it all right rat take my cheese there we go all right we're still oh wait did he give me the donuts no i just never clicked on it all right there we go all right we'll figure this out later okay uh we gotta go down here down down is red that the music room didn't let me play any music like it got me a little worried there just a little bit surely oh my god i'm fucking the eye i forgot about the eye let's just hope that you know that doesn't fuck me over that's whoa that'd be so awkward surely right surely that's not gonna bite me in the ass later let's grab the flashlight I don't trust you rats.
Alright, this way.
Alright, let's try the red door.
Red door time.
Ooh!
Alright, here we go.
Alright, I wish I could save.
Alright.
I'm so sad.
Um, wait, maybe I'm so sad
No No
I'm gonna softlock This I don't Wait, I got an idea Oh, I Re-accidentally Guys, I accidentally Oh, oh I fucked up, guys.
I...
I don't understand!
Why does it suck?
Oh, maybe you're right.
Okay.
Okay, no ad blocker.
Wait, is that it?
Is that it?
Is it because of ad blocker?
Is it...
We can do this!
I turned on it.
Okay.
All right.
We go straight.
Okay.
We're going to go straight to the red room.
For real this time.
I turned off my ad blocker.
I'm part of the problem.
I turned it off.
All right.
One more.
Take three.
This is why Lil Doki never like finished this game one time.
She played this for like.
Three plus years.
And she only beat it one time.
And it was the last time she played it.
That was hell.
I actually, I couldn't.
I never even beat.
The Cartoon Network trick-or-treat games too.
Because I never read.
This is it.
No!
I'm looking.
Google.
Someone Google.
There has to be.
There has to.
There has to be another, there has to be another Garfield scary scavenger hunt play, there has to be another version where I can play this, I refuse.
There has to be another site where I can beat this game.
What?
Okay, I found it.
I found it.
I won't be beat.
There you go.
I found another one.
I did it.
I must complete this for little dokey.
All right, here you go.
All right.
Got another one.
I found...
I found another one, but I have to, okay, we gotta redo this though.
I found another one, but I gotta redo this, so it works.
Alright, okay, look, I know it looks a little fuck-fuck-y right now, but it's because I had to find another version, so give me a sec.
Oh, alright.
I found another version that we can use.
All right.
Here we go.
And then, Scarameter.
All right.
There we go.
This should be it.
All right.
Now.
We got a speed run.
We got a speed run back to the red room.
All right.
Here we go.
I swear to God, I swear to God, if this person, another website i found i literally the only reason why i even went on the first one was because i googled i was like how do i play this and the guy was like oh my god i love this game by the way you can play it right now on this website and i was like whoa on this website let's go and like he got like all the updutes and everything too i knew he must have bonded the updutes he was fucking a bot in the uptutes.
Okay.
Guys, on the website, it's called play-games.com.
How fucked is my PC for Garfield?
Oh, bad guy!
Okay.
619...
6...
1...
9...
What is this, 17?
78?
Okay, 70.
That's what it was supposed to be.
to look like 70 by the way has the sound been okay entire time oh my there we go we did it we got the donuts oh my god we finally did it we should have used we should have used play doc play dash games.com this entire time silly me silly silly me why did i not go on play dash games now wait there's scary scavenger hunt too there's a second one i didn't even know there was a second one i've only knew about the scary scavenger hunt one wait is that real the monday curse has been subdued wait has anyone ever played the second one i didn't even know that existed and three there's a third one how do we do this
is it as good as the first one i don't know but no no I don't know.
Bump, bump, bump.
Okay, this is easy.
A child can do it.
And I am that child.
Bump.
Wait, what about the little trumpet?
Do we not care?
What the fuck about that trumpet?
You're right.
Wait, it keeps going?
A child cannot remember this.
Like, why would you do this to him?
I don't know.
Bump.
Jesus Christ, this is a long one.
All right.
This would have stopped his silk song.
Okay.
Yeah.
I did it!
I'm so smart.
I got it, guys.
I found a mini...
Oh, I would like some mini powder sugar donuts right now, honestly.
That sounds so good.
I love mini powder.
Did you guys see the new Simpsons Fortnite shit?
I actually really want to play it.
That looks so fucking fun.
They, like, turned everything into Simpsons.
That's so fucking crazy.
Yay!
I already got that.
look they turned the entire simpsons map uh entire fortnite map into simpsons it looks insane
yeah i really want to try it out maybe i'll try oh my gosh maybe i try it out next week
is it next does it start tomorrow give me that cheese oh wait i'll keep i mean you take that cheese all right we go this way wait i do anything outside i think the last stuff is like outside Because I forgot.
We were speed running.
Yeah, I have like two donuts.
I have to get fucking outside.
I don't even care about the Simpsons characters.
I just want to fucking fuck around in Springfield.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm not talking to the clown.
Okay, what did the bats want to do?
Hello.
Oh.
god i like how it's like written and i assume blood that's not like bad or anything right who's blood whoa garfield yeah okay so the last donut's outside oh my god i'm doing it hello toky it took me it took me three refreshes but we're doing it we're oh yeah Yeah,
oh yeah, you're right.
It's red paint.
Give me a sec.
We gotta go all the way down here.
We gotta go outside and go outside, grab the shovel, and then dig a graveyard and grave rob, I guess.
That's fine.
Jim Davis would approve of that.
I mean, Jim, Jim is teaching us that grave robbing is okay.
The curse has been lifted.
I just had to go to play-games.com.
Bye, John.
All right, here you go.
I'll go this way.
Sour cream donuts.
Did I say sour cream donuts?
Oh, my God.
Wait, you're right.
That's the only pair of donuts I'm missing.
Bro, what the fuck?
Has anyone ever tried sour cream donuts?
Americans.
Am I right?
I'm not right.
Yay, I found it pretty good.
What the fuck?
Just eat chips.
Why would you want sour cream?
Don't just eat chips.
Like a regular person.
Alright, we did it.
What happens now?
Oh, wait.
Blueberry.
Wait, where the fuck is the blueberry muffins?
Wait, where?
How?
Oh!
I forgot about the...
The rats.
Yeah, but wouldn't you...
That's like sweet and sour, isn't it?
I guess you use savory, so...
Because I personally like savory.
crepes.
I mean, I do like, you know, sweet crepes, too.
Tim Hortons has, yes, but who the fuck goes to Tim Hortons for regular donuts?
I'll go to Tim Hortons for Timbits.
How is sour cream sweet?
Okay, we gotta grab the flashlight here.
Talk to a muffin lover?
Who likes muffins?
Wait, what?
Where do I go?
What the fuck are those muffins here?
Okay, now I'm definitely lost.
Uh...
What the fuck?
Oh, hey!
What?
Beef's up?
Burry tales?
Stupid Cupid?
Garfield gets cooking?
Wait, what the fuck does any of this mean?
Like, I don't know what this means.
Is it supposed to be the rainbow?
I don't know the order of the rainbow.
Who the fuck knows the order of the rainbow?
Um.
Is it purple at the end?
Who the fuck knows the...
Who cares about the order of the rainbow?
Guys, rainbow flag.
Rainbow flag's in my chat right now.
Roy G.
Okay.
Gay?
How do we do this?
Red.
Orange.
Okay.
Yellow.
Rainbow in a question mark.
In my chat right now.
Wait.
Gay?
Okay.
Green.
um indigo what's i what is that what what is that i'm so lost is that in is that indigo is i for indigo why is it brown what the fuck is brown gotta do with rainbow wait blue Okay, now what?
I skipped blue.
I can barely see.
I think it's alphabetical.
There's no way it's alphabetical.
There's no A.
There's no...
No, this is red.
Why is there brown in my rainbow?
How did I ruin it?
You guys said red, orange, yellow, green, blue.
Red, yellow, green.
Orange, yellow, green, blue, indigo, violet.
Okay, indigo, violet.
Where the fuck did the...
Is that not right?
Oh, brown, first, purple, last?
Well, clearly we're both stupid.
We're...
Clearly!
Clearly we're both fucking stupid.
We're both wrong.
What do you mean first?
You mean this should have been first this entire time?
Teal before...
Guys, we're learning the rainbow right now.
Teal before blue.
Teal before blue?
Okay, how do we fix this?
Okay.
Red, orange, yellow, green.
blue oh wait didn't you guys say teal before oh my gosh wait red
red uh or mint and which oh orange yellow green mint blue blue What brown I guess then purple or purple.
Oh my god, where where the fuck does this go?
Wait, two of us between.
Wait, where the fuck does brown go?
Where the shit threw at the lap?
How did I throw?
What is this color?
It's brown.
Oh, this is brown.
This goes first?
Most likely.
Yellow.
Green.
Teal.
Blue.
Purple.
Okay.
We're both fucking stupid.
Like, none of us know.
We're all wrong.
Red.
Between the...
Okay.
Between...
Red.
Brown.
Orange, yellow, green, teal, blue, purple.
Now look who's stupid.
Look at that.
Okay, okay, I'm stupid.
I told you.
Wow.
Look at that.
There's no...
What the fuck?
What did they give us the rainbow?
Okay.
Blue before green.
Alright.
Red.
Teal.
Green.
Orange.
Now.
Alright guys.
We're all dumb.
We're all fucking stupid.
I guess.
None of us know what the rainbow is.
None of us know what the rainbow colors are deal before it is before green.
What do you mean?
This is before green.
Is it alphabetical?
How the fuck is this alphabet?
All right.
Blue before purple.
Okay, now I think you guys are fucking with me.
Now, lady, I just...
Okay.
Start with B.
What?
Beeps up?
Okay, beeps up.
Alright, what's next?
What's next after beeps up?
Please color be...
What's after beeps up?
Furry.
Okay, A, B, C, D, F.
G, H, I, J-K-L-M-N-O-P-S.
Oh my god, it was alphabetical the entire time.
It was, why the fuck did they made it rainbow?
And then gave us brown.
I, it was, it was alphabetical the entire time.
Okay, logically.
oh hey lineman logically i'm so hungry did you have any muffins oh there's lineman logically you would think that that'd be a rainbow because they gave us majority of the rainbow okay i got there's a vampire in here what do you mean it was a red herring it was actually a red herring they gave us all the all the rainbow colors and then brown.
The fuck with us.
I was like, where the fuck does the brown come from in rainbow?
Is that the light?
It's a library.
I don't know.
It's somebody's fucking bookshelf.
It's not a library.
It's someone's house.
I don't fucking I don't fucking coordinate my books to the fucking alphabet.
I would actually do it rainbow style Because it looks cool All right here Lyman Have a muffin Have you looked inside the fireplace yet?
I'm looking at Yes I used to have a book I used to actually read I know it's crazy to think about guys I actually used to read And had a giant ass I had like two bookshelves filled with books Well to be fair One, like, shelf was just filled with Garfield Comics.
But, like, look, I was a consumer of...
I consumed every type of book, okay?
It's not just Garfield.
It's not just comics.
I like all types of books.
Oh, there you go.
Yay!
I did it!
Garfield has found and eaten all of the donuts and muffins hidden inside.
We did it, guys!
Yay!
We did it.
The hardest part was the rainbow.
That was not rainbow.
Alright, let's do the... I actually never played a second game before.
I'm going to do that.
I didn't even realize the second game existed.
There's no third game, though, on this website.
I gotta know.
I gotta know what 2 is.
How did we go back into the haunted house?
Here we go.
Why did I come back?
Whoa!
Garfield presents Um
Donuts of Doom Um Bomb bomb bomb bomb bomb Where am I Oh wait I'm back in the dungeon I never leave Oh no I'm back in the haunted house Garfield is trapped in a haunted house One sec someone should just do my this house if it's haunted honestly why the fuck did you not do we not demolish if a house is haunted we just fucking bulldoze that shit it's like the murder house click on it and pick look anywhere but watch out for the really scary things okay don't worry I don't get scared it's very oh wait it's literally they're just copying and pasted the same assets okay the furnace it out it means oh grab the bone Maybe,
maybe, like, I'll find Odie.
Odie goon here.
Oh, oh, I got...
Oh, wait, I can light the furnace with that.
There's something here I can't see.
Wow, I wonder if, like, you know, there's a vampire hidden in that crypt.
Alright.
What happened to...
Yay!
Why would I go this way?
There's, like, a little piece there.
that was obviously oh wait oh i found an empty donut box oh all right we're not gonna question that yeah i found i knew there was something here oh what the fuck that scares me okay i okay you know i'm trying to get this out but it's not letting me yet so i thought maybe maybe the answer lies in the fucking spooky ass script wait what oh my god it's another floating skull.
Yeah, I kind of see in the dark.
Wait, you're right.
I should be able to see in the dark.
Wait, where the fuck could I go now?
Where else can I go?
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
It's because it was...
Sorry, I didn't have it.
Like...
What's it called?
I didn't have, like, OCD, so it didn't matter to me.
oh my god why the fuck how do i not see that perspective wise like wouldn't i be able to see that mummy like just there oh my god that's an exposed brain i could literally just kill the dog if i just stuck my finger in his brain um okay no that looks very angry television oh one donut
It's called acting.
Oh, shit.
Well, I thought we were...
What?
I thought we cool.
I thought we cool like that.
I don't know.
I feel like there's a...
Oh, nice and a donut.
I don't know.
I feel like...
I feel like that bear...
I feel like the bear might not be a good bear.
Might not be a nice bear.
It's a cool skeleton.
Then why did I go scary mode?
I said I don't have to open any of the...
Hello, do you need help spelling as well?
You need a newspaper to swap them?
Bro, they're just chilling.
I thought I'm friends with the spiders.
Oh, shit.
I don't know.
I thought...
Oh, wait, there it is.
I got a bobby pin.
What am I going to do with a bobby pin?
I got more donuts.
I guess I'm unlocking a safe.
That's usually what bobby pins are for.
Is he still there?
Hey, John!
Oh, nice.
I got a newspaper.
All right, time to swap the spotters.
Hey, John, why is your dead girl?
Why is your girlfriend dead and beheaded, John?
Huh?
Oh, no.
We have a Dalmer here.
All right, time to swap them.
What?
How?
What are you even wrong?
What am I supposed to- Okay, whatever.
Alright.
John has a little secret.
What happened to- What happened to me?
What am I supposed to- There you go.
Yeah, I fucking knew it.
Oh no, this is bad.
Oh, this is bad.
I'm on turn now.
Oh no, I keep clicking things.
Oh no, not the bats.
Okay.
Oh, that's a lot of muffins.
I don't know how they...
Like, at this point, this is more than a box.
Like, where did you get all these muffins?
Okay, yay!
Chocolate chip muffins!
Let's go.
I'm still at Eater, so I'm a little scared right now.
That's right.
You saw that?
I was gaming.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know if I can click it.
anything.
Oh my god, I'm not gonna click it.
No, I'm not gonna risk it.
I need five more items.
I'm not, I'm not doing so well.
My heart, if I get scared four more times, my heart will explode.
Let's see.
Oh my god, I don't want to click anything.
Anything else here?
Oh no, not a button.
And then like in, in the second game, game it's actually rainbow are you fucking kidding me oh no I'm a turn now guys it ain't looking good for me I actually might have a heart attack I only found one donut Jesus oh wait oh so my door appears to be stuck.
At least it won't make me do... Oh my god, there's so many things I want to click, but I can't click them.
I can't click them.
I don't want to do that again.
Oh, yay!
Are you serious to get donuts?
I have to give myself a heart attack!
Oh, hey.
It's the bomb urine ones.
I actually used to... I have the...
You must find the to get out.
I actually used to have, like, the little DVDs of, like, the Garfield animations.
I'll study this picture very closely.
What's wrong with this picture?
I'm studying.
Guys, I can't get out of this picture.
Guys?
Ah!
Serious at camera.
Oh my
god How do I remember this too?
I must guys Remember this pattern for me I just Oh my god Okay Okay guys remember this pattern I assume you'll do it for me I will admit Better than FNAF
Better than FNAF How do we even I believe in you guys Oh my god what you asked Okay guys okay We'll do it by numbers Just type okay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 Alright type the numbers for me I know the first one was 1 Oh my god If the first one wasn't one, was it?
Is it three?
Oh, it was two, three, three, three.
It wasn't one, was it, guys?
Oh, one, three, three, three, four, five, five, five, four.
I know you guys are fucking me up right now.
This does not look right.
We have, we have more notes here.
Three, four, okay.
Three, four, five.
And then how does it end?
How does this end?
Guys, how does this end?
We have one life.
Alright, let's look at it again.
I have a feeling that...
Oh, wait, it's upside down.
Was he always upside down?
I have a feeling...
Because I'm like...
I'm one life away from dying and no one's gonna get the inheritance.
Okay, yeah.
is it all the way down here is that not four okay guys all right one two three that's four guys it wasn't even three it was four one four four four five six six five oh my god i was sabotaging the very okay guys remember this type type it out no that's four one two three four
all right one four four four five six six five four five six four five six four five six four okay we got this kids back then did not have phone cameras how the fuck how the fuck did we do this do we i guess we had to draw it out on a piece of paper like old school style all right yeah
three four four four five six six six five four five six four there we go we did it Bum, bum, bum.
Yay!
We got the donuts!
Okay, ER.
God, I'm about to head to the ER.
Okay, now I'm scared to touch anything.
Because I feel like to progress, I have to touch something.
Oh, this is bad.
This is very bad.
Can I come out of the house?
No, I can't.
Wait, where the fuck do I?
I go?
Oh, there's a donut here.
Oh, my God.
I know, like, I'm missing a lot of stuff.
Because, like, I have, I need to find four more donuts.
The duck was, like, you gotta find, I don't know.
I don't know if I can click that.
I don't know if I should click it either.
Like, there could be a donut hidden in that area.
Or a donut hidden in these two cabinets.
Or a donut hidden in here oh wait i'm a bobby pin are you okay watch out for sneaky mice that's it that's it what are the mice gonna do rob me put a gun to my head and fucking shank me in the in the ankles yeah it's orson yeah what the fuck what happened to you oh my god john's i knew it i knew john was Dolmer?
I don't even remember his first name.
Did you find the patterns?
Oh, he's the hint guy.
Alright.
You must find... Did you find the patterns?
Okay, I feel like I did everything.
Oh, Jeff Dolmer.
Yeah!
Okay, we have three more donuts.
We have turn now.
Oh, wait.
It's back to normal.
I don't know where to go.
I'm scared.
A spooky scary.
Like, anything I could click could be dangerous.
Okay, I feel like all of these are, like, actually dangerous.
I don't know.
They could all just fucking get up and kill me.
Nothing in the bear.
Who are you, Christopher?
Alright.
Are you willing to bet your cat?
Count on this, Christopher?
Are you ready to the bet?
I will ban you.
All right, goodbye.
Where are you, Christopher?
That's right.
24 hours.
I hope you think about your actions.
I...
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Trying to send me the ER.
He said nothing there.
Yeah.
That's right.
No one fucks with me.
Alright.
That's right.
I took him out back.
And he's not home anymore.
That's right.
I call the DSA on him.
He's got a way in the...
He's got a way at the airport now.
That's right.
I ain't babysitting you anymore.
We're sending you back to your original dokeyverse.
I don't know where to go.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I need to find three more donuts.
Oh, wait, what?
When did this open?
Oh, hey.
Oh, it's...
It's whack-a-mice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm supposed to...
Oh, I'm supposed to whack the muffins.
Sorry, whack-a-muffin.
I was so confused.
I was like, wait, what the fuck?
How the fuck up?
I got him.
Yay!
Okay, we need...
Oh my god, we still need, like...
We still need two more.
How do we get to the other two?
Is there any...
Phone a friend.
Phone a chat.
What do I do?
How do I get to the bookshelf?
The bookshelves locked.
How do I get in?
No, I did.
I picked the lock.
It was for Orson.
I can't even go outside.
See?
It's just there.
I don't know.
It's just existing.
I can't open these.
I feel like there'd be stuff here.
I don't know.
I don't trust these cabinets.
oh my god i don't know i don't know i only have i only have three clicks
well i used the matches to light up the i already used the matches to light up the furnace so we can see i got health despair all right it's time to gamble oh hey oddy how am i scared of him he's fucking he's a fucking idiot idiot okay do we gamble the last one or do we open something else i understand who's scared of odys just stupid oh wait he's gone again click on the mirror in the bathroom i swear to god who said that are Are you willing to bet your account on that?
All right.
Oh, you're so lucky.
You're so...
Oh, no!
Okay, that's fine.
I know how to do puzzles.
It's like here.
Donuts.
I don't fucking know where this...
Oh, it goes here.
Okay, and then piece it together.
Yeah, I think the first one was better.
I like the first one more than the second one.
We just need assorted donuts now.
Alright.
How do we get the assorted donuts?
I feel like the assorted donuts is in that bookshelf.
It's in the rainbow bookshelf.
Trey in the dining room?
Is this?
Oh my god, it was here all along?
Oh!
Oh no.
It's over here.
Yay!
Okay, nice.
We did it again.
That's right, I'm winning.
If I blink, I fuck up.
Yay!
Best?
No.
Yay!
I did it!
Oh, wait.
Rainbow, Rainbow Library.
Rainbow Shelf.
Oh, my God.
It's the exit.
It's a maze.
Always go right.
Okay.
Okay, no.
Always go left.
I meant...
I meant left, guys.
Always go left.
And this way.
And then we go this way.
Oh, no.
I don't like this.
Why is there so much more to this maze?
When does it end?
I swear to you guys, this is dead and I have to backtrack my way back here.
I went through so...
Hey Furball, I know the secret code.
But you have to hit me again.
Not me, mouse, breath.
The other one.
The secret code is 8, 4, 2, 9.
9.
Okay, 8, 4, 2, 9, 9.
That's easy.
8, 4, 2, 9.
9.
Oh, that's easy.
He wasn't gonna fuck with me.
Yay!
I did it!
What did I get?
I got a screen saver.
Does Windows 11 even have screen?
Oh my oh my god, that's throwback.
Oh my god, I miss screen savers.
Remember I, wait, can I actually download that?
Absolutely nothing.
I'll see if I can download this.
Oh, Microsoft Windows.
Oh, it actually doesn't let you download anything.
Wait, what game is this?
Unfortunately, it did not let me download a screen saver.
But then I saw this game and I was like, wait, I feel this.
Wait, this resonates with me.
me right now oh never mind
guys i think the game doesn't work i think
oh my god the entire all the entire website is literally garfield games wait what's this so i can play this damn you it's not in the cloud why isn't it in the cloud how could this be wait what's this oh my god we gotta play this game guys guys it's the pay attention so i don't have to all right let's do hard i got this the garfield memory game all right you have the attention span of a puppy
maybe you can learn better with repetition voice acted this Look at it.
I did it!
Now I'm forever...
What a lovely picture to have.
And what?
What's medium like?
Pay attention.
Okay.
That's not right.
Wait, how is this harder?
Wait, this is harder.
Okay, nice.
I did it.
Wait.
Maybe you can learn.
There's more.
Oh, wait.
Okay, okay.
I gotta do this again.
actually no this was harder oh my god i already forgot okay do i just keep clicking oh no this is bad oh my god i'll be no we'll do easy maybe you can oh this is from screenshots of the movie that's why oh because the other one is like pay attention it's like harder because it's like they all looked similar that's not right we did it we're so good thanks garfield good at guessing.
I remember, guys.
Wait, what else do they have?
What else do they have?
Oh my god, they have, um, what is this?
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Garfield, wait, Garfield hidden number.
Oh my god, hidden alphabet.
Oh, I want to play beat.
Wait, undergar.
What the fuck is this?
I need to know what this is.
It's called Undergarve.
Oh, wait, it's probably Lumpy Touch?
Wait, I love Lumpy Touch.
Bad Monday Simulator.
Okay.
How do I play this?
Oh, no.
I'm going to have a bad that you don't feel any remorse.
Okay.
Sun.
All right.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
It's just, oh, my God.
It's just a sad fight.
It's becoming a real cat fight.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God.
What the fuck?
You don't feel any remorse.
Get him!
Oh, God.
Oh, my!
I'm dead.
Jay.
Wait, we got...
Wait, wait.
We have to beat this.
I beat it in every version of Sands.
Wait, what is on my item?
Oh, I got lasagna.
Wait, I don't want to...
Wait, how do I...
spaces.
Oh no, I don't want to eat it.
Guys, what were the controls?
What were the controls?
I don't want to eat it.
Escape?
I don't have an escape button.
Alright.
Spaghetti.
Guys, this might not be the winning run.
Oh no.
Oh my god, this is so hard.
Oh, I... Okay.
It's okay.
We got the center.
We're dead.
I need to plug in...
Okay, God.
I have to plug in my other keyboard for this.
Because I don't have...
I don't have...
Arrow key.
I got this.
Lasagna.
I got my arrow key.
We gotta beat.
We beat every version of Sands.
Garfield Sands is no different.
We beat every version.
We will beat this one too.
Try again.
Alright.
I have arrow keys now.
What's prey?
Normal prey.
Oh shit!
A tiny rock bounces off of Sandsfield.
all right i'm locking the in but i'm finding out a little oh my god oh my god this is so intense all right i don't that's right get out of here sam's beard oh my god what the fuck oh my oh shit oh picky
I can't do this.
Okay, I did not expect Pookie to come in here.
Oh, it's no mercy.
Alright.
It's okay.
The Pookie Blasters got me.
Okay.
Alright.
You guys.
I'm not praying.
Normal does jack shit.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
It follows me.
Wait, it follows me.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Where is my pipe?
Okay.
Oh!
God!
All right, my lasagna.
It's lasagna time.
Okay.
All right, the only one is not as bad.
The only one I can live with the only one.
The where is my pipe.
That one's hard.
That one is pretty difficult.
Oh No
What the fuck are you?
Okay, I got you spaghetti.
It's spaghetti time Yeah, Jim Davis the gas tank of this man with two suits papyrus Oh god.
Oh god.
Oh god
I'm just gonna I'm gonna wing it.
Oh, no.
The pokey blaster.
Pokey blasters.
Who knew Sanfield?
Who is?
Oh, my God, not him.
No, no.
I don't.
I'm not fast enough.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I'm not fast enough, but it's okay.
holy shit oh
that's that's a little aque what the fuck was that it's because like you know it was Too easy, you know?
Where is...
Where is my pipe?
It got too easy, guys.
I had to give myself a little challenge.
Alright.
Oh!
Goddamn, Odie!
Wait, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Can I adjust the difficulty?
Okay, we got this.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh, dude.
We have to hear this on you.
Um, yum, yum, yum, yum.
All right.
I don't know how.
Oh, my God.
This is impossible.
This is just not balanced.
This is not balanced.
This is
not...
Oh!
Like the ODs, the ODs are fine.
It's just every other fucking thing he puts me through.
Just dodge, bro.
Just dodge.
Oh.
Oh no, where's my pipe?
Where is my pipe?
Like, I can dodge this, but then he goes, God, fear!
I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna shank him.
Oh, God, why did I?
I'm sorry.
God, fear!
Just pray.
Nirmal, please.
Oh, thank God.
Nirmal actually did something.
He was paralyzed.
Oh, my God, he's paralyzed.
I should have prayed.
Oh my god.
It does more than just a rock.
I thought that was it.
Are you?
Are you kidding me?
That was so free.
Maybe?
Nirmal.
Please keep praying.
Oh my god.
Nirmal, just keep praying.
Oh no.
Where?
Where is my fight?
Oh, God.
That was an accident.
At the end of the side, yeah.
The power of fear.
All right.
No, no, no.
This is so bullshit.
Okay.
I gotta pray.
Nirmal will keep praying.
for me oh
okay okay that's just a rock a tiny rock all right okay that's what I could do when he kicks already I could do that okay I
got to make sure I know normal has the super attack Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I can't.
Okay, guys.
I guess I have to eat my own lasagna.
Okay.
Normal RNG.
It might not be like a plan, guys.
Might not be it.
I might not.
Maybe I should not rely on.
Wait, what if one more time?
What if...
Oh.
okay oh nice oh I got hit too not nice where is my butt
okay oh
my god oh my god it's not looking so good for me it's not it's not guys I
guys I guys I I don't It's on We'll do this another time
Guys I don't know I don't know if I could ever be This has to be its own thing Don't surrender But he's It's so bullshit It's so bullshit It's like he attacks They're un- dodgeable okay where is my pipe all
right oh
my god i'm too scared of praying because i feel like it's it's too rng are you serious all right 30 i don't even know how many hits i have
No!
Ah!
This is on you!
Okay, this is on you!
Okay, this is fine.
It's OD tag.
Oh!
Oh my god, okay.
Usually I never get hit by those.
Oh!
Okay.
I just gotta be determined Okay, I'm halfway Oh my god It's the blasters The blasters are so bullshit The blasters are broken The pokey blasters They're so broken There's no way to dodge them How do you dodge that?
Oh my god There's no way There's no fucking way to dodge the stupid God damn pokey blasters Like, they're actually undodgeable!
Okay, 27.
Skill issue.
What?
My greatest enemy.
The greatest challenge yet.
Okay.
He's like seven hits, I think.
Ah!
Lasagna!
Where?
Where is my pipe?
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, this is my pipe.
Does not feel so good for me.
Alright.
Oh, two more hits.
Three more hits.
It's literally...
Oh my god!
I think I need my spaghetti.
I need my...
Alright.
Okay, okay.
Alright, now where...
Where is my pipe?
Okay.
God.
All right.
I think...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
They gave me a freebie here.
Do I risk it?
Do I risk it with Nirmah?
Do I trust in the almighty Nirmah?
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, oh.
Do I do it?
do I trust do I throw it all on normal do I do I believe do I believe derma
what happened what what happened to me oh my god dermal dermal please what I'm fucking I'm gonna just go that.
Fuck this.
I don't know.
Just keep me out of here.
Yeah, take me out of here.
There's a phase two.
What do you mean?
Okay.
This time.
Nerval.
Almighty Nerval.
Oh, 36.
Wait, that's so good.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where is my fight?
It helped.
I just, I just was like, why did that just...
Okay, I just hit it up.
We're joking.
Oh no.
It's fine.
We gave us an OD.
Cha-cha!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he touched me.
You see that?
It went to 99.
Alright.
We can't do this.
I don't know how to...
I don't know how to... I don't know how to do this one.
This is actually the worst one.
The Pokee Blasters are the worst one.
Like it's actual pure bullshit.
no the circle hurts me guys the circle hurts oh my look see yeah the who said that who's like go inside the circle circle does circle hurts guys the circle indeed
Oh It's fine Science field you're going down No, no, JK, JK, JK, JK, JK JK, JK, JK, JK, JK, JK, JK, JK, JK, JK, JK, JK
I'm so sad.
Why does he do this to me?
Why does Satisfield do this to me?
Oh!
All I'm saying is...
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
Where is my butt?
Okay.
Oh,
my God.
Please.
Okay.
Am I facing?
No!
Not the Pokeblasters!
Anything with the Pokeblasters!
Oh!
It's always...
It's always the Pokeblasters.
If I...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Okay.
At least I remember the Odies.
The fact that I don't even get, like, you know, like, you know, like, Sands, at least he gives you, like, moments to, like, to chill.
He doesn't.
Sandsfield does not care.
I'll never escape Monday.
I'm so scared of Phase 2.
Like, there's no way to dodge any of this!
It's not me!
There's no fucking way!
Oh!
Oh, my god.
Have you just...
Have you just tried not getting it?
Oh, wow, guys.
This is crazy.
What a crazy idea.
Wow!
Oh, my god.
No.
That's like the most HP I've ever got out of that.
I don't think I've ever had.
That's literally...
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Alright, you're my lasagna.
I'm yam-yam-yam-yam.
I think I dodged the beams, dude.
Oh shit, really?
Oh my god.
No!
What is that?
Oh my god.
Where is my fight?
I looked at chat.
Oh fuck!
Guys, don't look at chat.
It might be a bad thing to do.
What is that?
Okay.
I think I eat my spaghetti.
Okay, I'm 40 HP.
Oh my god.
Not him again.
Where is my pipe?
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think I can heal anymore.
If I heal, it's over.
Every time.
It's always the boogie blaster.
Every fucking time.
I need the RNG to give me five ODs in a row.
That's the only way I can win this.
The OD guys must look upon me and give me five ODs in a row.
It's actually like the most balanced game.
Like...
Where is my fight?
Okay,
you can take half my HP, I guess.
I guess.
Oh, I leave me alone.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Where is...
Bye-bye
Okay, this one this one is not as bad I wish I would get this more often this and OD
Jesus Oh Jesus Okay 17 Okay, here we go Watcha!
Watcha!
Oh god.
Oh my god, he's been kicking for so long.
Oh my god, please.
Can you go to sleep?
No!
Where...
Where is my pipe?
Bring in the Funky Blasters!
Please!
Not the Funky Blasters!
Hey!
Oh, God!
Is there anything but a Pokeblasters?
Alright, I pray to Nirmal.
I pray to Nirmal here.
Oh, my God!
Okay.
Nirmal, please.
Nirmal, only you can...
Oh, oh, the boogie blasters are here.
Derva was a false god.
He was a false god.
I do.
Wait, maybe unless.
Oh my god, thank god.
Oh my god, Derva.
I do.
Why couldn't you do that first?
Oh my god.
Okay, we're going to take.
chop chop oh my god i don't know why suddenly i was like it didn't hit me i i'll i'll change that okay
odie time
oh it's okay things are okay for now just give me burger and odie just give me burger and odie we don't need Okay.
Oh
my god.
That's the least damage it's ever done to me.
That's...
Woo!
Oh my god.
Wait.
I'm locking in.
Oh no.
Here we go.
Where is my fight?
Alright.
all
right we'll eat lasagna after this oh i could oh no i should have eaten lasagna oh my god why oh my god
i'll break i'll eat it lasagna mondays am i right
mondays guys
Oh, Mondays are so crazy.
Oh, my God.
I didn't mean to pray to him.
Oh, thank God.
I did mean to pray to him.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I actually did mean to pray to him.
guys oh my god just hit i hit everything
okay after this i eat my lasagna where where is my pipe i pray the mondays away
i'm just throwing Okay, I didn't say I was gonna eat the lasagna here.
It was it was planned Oh God, oh no, no, no
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
He goes to sleep here, right?
No, okay.
It's fine
Okay I'm so focused right now
Okay, sleep time Phase two What the fuck?
There's no way There's no way I Don't know how I I don't know how how do you do it?
Oh my god, how is it done?
How do you do it?
Oh my god.
Do I just like do this?
What?
No, no.
Oh my god.
I'd rather have the sheep.
I don't know what the sheep does, but I'd rather have it.
Oh
my god.
Oh, where is my butt?
Okay, I'm locking in.
Oh, shit!
Okay, um, I'm locking in now.
Are you serious?
Okay.
29.
Oh, my God.
Leave me alone.
I locked.
guys I don't know if I'm strong enough I don't know I don't know if I'm strong enough I feel like I'm actually in hell I'm in like my own little purgatory and it's all Garfield it's all it's all sandsfield I can't escape I can't escape him oh my god i'm just gonna i'm gonna die here oh my god yeah no i'm dead here where is my butt i don't know it's just it's just all sandfield i can't it's just mondays everywhere i look I'm a banana,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, bro.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
17, are you fucking kidding me?
I might as well be dead.
Is my fight.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay, I sort of figured out the pattern for that.
I sort of, I think I figured it out.
Woo!
Oh, whoop, it's fine, it's fine.
It's just a little.
I just chipped my toe.
It's chipped my toe.
It's okay.
It's always the boogie blasters.
It's always him.
It's never been anything else.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Center.
The pookster senses are guys.
Okay, please just give me five ODs.
That's all I want.
Five ODs in a row.
Just give me that RNG.
That's all I want.
Oh, oh, where is my pipe?
Where is it?
Where is your pipe?
Why do you keep losing your pipe, John?
Oh my gosh.
Lasagna.
Where's the pipe, John?
Where is it?
oh my god where is my pipe
oh god okay two more hits maybe the world will finally oh god never mind never mind didn't hold my jump key enough where is the giant.
And now all the jokies will remember the fight.
Okay.
It's sleep time.
Sheep, sheep, sheep.
Where is my fight?
Where did the pipe go, Josh?
Where did it go?
Where did the little pipe go?
I'd almost had it.
It was... it was right there.
I almost had it!
I don't understand!
touched me i fucking touched me oh my god nice
this is sleep time no it's never sleep time it's spooky time it's spooky blasters oh my god i have to eat a spaghetti i can't do the sleep thing with that much hp Please, please give me an OD.
Oh, my...
Where is my pipe?
Where is it?
Where could my pipe be?
Guys, we're gonna go in there with 31 HP.
Oh, it's getting lower.
It's...
Why is
it...
Wait, what?
Oh my god, I'm just gonna pray.
There's no hope anymore.
Sparkles with sand spilling and repeals refreshed.
Oh, okay.
Oh, he got HP too.
That's cool.
Equality, am I right?
They knew after I finally understood the assignment.
Oh, they sent it to the other side.
I saw the sheep one time and I never saw him again.
They, like, took the sheep to the back of the farm.
Let's just put it.
It is not the run.
I already know.
I already know it was not the run.
I'm very freaking...
I knew.
I knew it wasn't the run.
We couldn't do that one.
okay this is it where is my pipe oh
my god I don't know what I don't know what's going on this is not the run anymore I no longer believe I no longer believe anywhere how am I getting worse I just I accepted it I had to kill off this for this run i have to kill him off you don't understand you don't understand we pray we pray to our false god yay oh my god thank god oh my god please where is my life why is it always you
oh god all right
Oh no.
Karaoke is for winners.
Only winners get karaoke.
Oh.
The blue flag is this, you guys.
We can do this.
Oh my, stop!
I don't want to fight your fight!
Please, please!
There's other fucking games!
Okay.
Please stop making your cat smoke!
Why couldn't he just give me seven ODs in a row?
I don't understand.
understand why oops okay I just need seven odys just just seven odys and then and then the run the run won't be dead okay and then we eat lasagna after this oh my god if I live I can live.
Okay.
Okay, we just still need lasagna.
No, Quail, don't say that.
Don't say that, Quail.
Oh, my God.
Look what you did.
You threw me off my group.
Oh.
But yeah, I have to eat spaghetti.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Why did they send me 20 ODs in a row?
Like, like...
I mean, I want...
No, that's good.
That's good that he did.
Okay.
Guys, I'm not strong enough.
Because I don't think I'm strong enough.
Because I don't know.
I don't, I don't know if I can keep going anymore.
I don't know.
There's a phase three.
What do you mean there's a phase three?
You get worse?
Where is my fight?
Okay, I'll do one more.
I'll do one more.
And then this deserves its own stream at this point.
This deserves its own stream.
What the fuck does time segment even mean?
This is harder than the sands, but 100%.
I believe this is harder.
Oh my god.
Where is my fight?
Oh god, he took up so much of my HP.
Oh my god.
God, someone save me.
Okay, if I live through this, I'll eat a lasagna.
Lasagna.
I need a pipe now.
Oh my God.
This is so bullshit.
This is such a bullshit.
attack.
This is harder than Sans.
This is harder.
This is 100% harder than this actual Sans fight.
Day back.
Like, oh my god.
The gastric plaster was easier.
The poop.
Oh my.
I'm done.
I can't.
I'm going fucking crazy I can't keep going I'm not strong enough I don't want to find the pipe no more I can't keep trying to find the pipe I can't oh my god why would he Why would he do this to me?
Why would he do this?
Oh, where is my pipe?
Now we'll never know.
Just give him the pipe.
Okay, one more.
I'll do one more.
One more.
I'll pray to Nirmal.
Nirmal, please.
help me.
Oh, thank God.
I'm locking in.
No, yeah.
Just determination.
Oh, my God.
I almost touched me.
Where is my pipe?
Okay.
My god!
Okay, that one was bullshit.
That one was actually bullshit.
What?
What do you mean, kid you?
Not tonight.
Not...
Monday wins again.
It's one hit.
Okay.
Maybe, you know, let's pray to Nerval.
Maybe Nerval lock the fuck in.
Guys, maybe, maybe Nerval will help me, guys.
Maybe.
Oh Oh
Okay Okay
Because I wasn't because that was that was that one in that you guys didn't kill the akasufa
It was because it was It was not, guys, it wouldn't even let me pray.
I think Nervo, I think Nervo peace out after what we both saw.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure even Nervo was like, I'm out of nowhere.
You're on your own.
That, yeah, I had a feeling that was not one hit, guys.
He dipped out.
I literally couldn't do anything.
but fight that that was everything it gave me all right all right i guess i guess give me a second you know i thought phase three was the alarm clock silly me that's silly me for thinking that phase three was the fucking alarm clock.
I was like, oh my god, I did it.
I beat phase three.
Oh my god.
We like, oh my god.
We fucking did it.
We beat phase three.
And then, anyway, I'm in the murder house now.
I'm in the murder.
I deserve to die.
Anyway, we're in.
This is a lost, found footage now.
We have to after after fine fighting sansfield we're in we're in the found footage area now i mean that tracks yeah this is where yes sansfield sent me here afterwards he fucking he was slapped my ass into into into this murder house yeah i'm in my own blare witch project now
One day, one day we'll be, we've, we've beaten every version of Sands, but yet somehow, Sandsfield is somehow the strongest Sands of them all.
Who would have thought, who would have thought Sandsfield was the strongest Sands of them all?
All right.
We're not winners, but like, bro, like, what can I do?
can I do it?
What can I do in that situation?
Oh my god, I need this.
Oh, I wish this was a remix version.
The remix version is even, it's so good.
I love the remix version.
All right, here we go.
I think that's enough for you, babe.
I don't even know if sound guy is alive.
I don't even know.
I'll sing my troubles away.
Uh, shine just what?
Streak cheek scars will shock your soul.
Seal your doom tonight.
Spooky scary skeleton.
Speak with such a streak.
Shake and shudder in surprise.
when you hear these zombies streak.
We're so sorry, Skeletons, you are so misunderstood.
You only want to socialize, but I don't think we should.
A spooky, scary science field shout, starting shrilly screens.
They'll sneak from their sarcophagus and just won't leave you be.
He's coming to get you!
Oh!
Science field is coming to get you!
Whoa!
Spirit's supernatural I shy what's all the fuss But bags of bones seem so unsafe It's semi-serious Spooky, scary, science field Are silly all the same They'll say Smile and scrabble slowly by and drive you so insane.
Six and stones will break your bones.
They seldom let you snooze.
Spooky, scary, sand field will wake you with...
Oh, I don't know why.
I didn't even practice a song.
I have the remix version of this.
I just went in blind.
I will say I will say the remix version is a lot better I think the remix version is a lot better than the the original it's even more spooky it's very spooky wow yeah no rehearsal Oh, you don't know that this one?
This one's fun.
This one's awesome.
This one's also pretty spooky.
Oh, we have up the volume.
Don't worry.
Five.
Snuck in kitchen late at night.
Nate, a donut with a maple glaze.
Oh!
My father asked who ate that snack.
I said that if what was my brother Jack.
and Jack got grounded for 14 days.
I've lived with that guilt all of my life and a terrible vision that I had that night.
Please, I don't want to go back.
Down, down, his soul is cast from the earth when Sporky fell.
The path of fire leads the sea to spooky Mormon hell dream.
Welcome back to spooky Mormon hell dream.
You are having a spooky Mormon hell dream now.
And now I've gone and done it again.
Come in another awful sin.
I like my mission companion all alone.
Spokiness.
Oh God, how could I have done this to you how could I break rule 72 and now my soul have just been thrown back into spooky Mormon hell dream Satan's realm see where you belong there is nothing you can do no escape from spooky Mormon hell dream you blamed your brother for eating a donut now you walk out of your mission companion ah you're a dick.
Jesus, I'm sorry!
Jesus hates you, this we know, for Jesus has told you so.
You remember Lucifer, he is even spookier!
Yeah!
Municipalities, have you heard the news?
Kevin was caught playing hooky.
Now he's back with all you Catholics and Jews.
It's super spooky, wookie.
I mean Lord it was selfish of me to break the rules please I don't want to be in the spooky Mormon hell dream spooky Mormon and hell dream Genghis gang Jeffrey Dahmer Hitler Joe and Cochran the spirits all around you spooky spooky spooky
Oh, I can't say that.
I can fuck this corpse.
I can say that.
J-Freeed.
And that's bad.
I've worked for 72.
I left my companion.
I'm way worse than you.
Ain't this spooky Mormon hell dream.
Mormon hell dream.
Oh, Heavenly Father.
Oh, please give me all my chance.
I won't break the rules again.
A spooky Mormon helldream from the book of Mormon.
It's written by our guys that so far.
I don't know if that seems obvious.
It is spooky.
It's Halloween.
Can't believe Jesus called me a day!
Welcome to Spooky Mormon Helldream.
You are never waking up from spooky Mormon Helldream.
Help this hell be fodder.
Please let me wake up.
Give me one more chance.
I won't let you down again.
Spooky Mormon Helldream, y'all!
Yeah.
That is Spooky Mormon Helldream from the Book of Mormon.
And I felt like, you know, that's like me.
I feel like that's the only month that where it's appropriate to sing that song.
I don't know if the music's too loud or anything else.
I hope sound got.
is okay with the sound volume
um stay hydrated spooky mormon i actually watched the book of mormon um live on broadway with the urgent cast with like josh gad and the other guy i don't remember before josh gad before i uh became like you know where he was just became an industry plant um I actually watched the Book of Mormon on Broadway with the original cast.
It was good.
And then I watched it with a friend.
I told this story before, but I watched this with a friend.
I bought tickets for my friend and her little brother.
And I thought her little brother was like a teenager because he's like taller than her.
And then like, you know, because the Book of Mormon is not very appropriate.
musical and then later on she was like yeah my brother's like 10.
i was like what and like because after the musical it was like because like you know during broadways um she didn't afford me she was like yeah i'm gonna bring my brother to the book of mormon and then and then so the like in the musical there's a section where um it's about fucking frogs to get rid of AIDS and um and then the third year you know they would sell like souvenirs and like gifts based off the music club and and one of them was the frog where the frog that you fuck to get rid of AIDS and then the little brother was like I want to buy the frog the AIDS frog but like he didn't say that it is like to the dad I want can I buy the plushie plush frog but he knows what it means he and then the dad you know he didn't come to the musical he went to pick us up and obviously he was none the wiser as to what the fuck the context was to the AIDS frog so he was like yeah sure of course I'll buy you the fucking plushie frog and And I'm like,
and then, and then my friend was like, yeah, he's 10.
And I was like,
and that's when I know I'm going to go to spooky Mormon hell.
That's when I knew it's over for me.
I'm heading there.
I'm heading to spooky Mormon hell.
There's nothing I can do.
There's nothing.
What have you done to- I didn't know!
How was I supposed to know?
How- I don't understand.
He was dead.
He was taller than her!
He was- He was so much taller than her.
He was taller than me!
I can't even give him- I didn't fully feed him.
It's like, give me a sec.
I did only feed you fucking gaslighting.
Okay.
He he he ate everything.
I was What?
No, no.
You're you ate.
You ate.
You are not gaslighting me.
I literally looked at the cans and I was like, wait a minute.
There's no more food in these cans.
more he fucking tried to gaslight me and then giving him more food i don't know that was like the only oh i mean i was gonna see that's the only halloween songs i know but i was like wait i have this
i don't know what songs are spooky i don't know whether spooky songs are in this part Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Boys and girls of every age, when you'd like to see something strange, come with us and you will see this our town of Halloween.
This is Halloween, this is Halloween, pumpkin scream in the dead of night.
Halloween, everybody make us be trick or true.
Till the Navy's gonna die right.
Pips are our towns.
Everybody's green.
In the town of Halloween.
One hiding under your bed.
Deep ground sharp and eyes glowing red.
I am the one hiding under your stairs.
Fingers like snakes and spiders in my air.
This is Halloween.
Halloween.
Yeah!
In the town.
With the home, everyone hailed to the pumpkin song In this town, don't we love it now?
Everybody's waiting for the next surprise Round that corner mat, hiding in the trash Yeah, something's waiting down, pouncing how you scream This is Halloween, red and black is climbing green Aren't you scared?
Well, that's just fine Say it once, say it twice, take a chance and roll a dice Ride with the moon in the dead of night Everybody's green, everybody's green And the sound of Halloween Hearing the flash and gow about a trace I am the who when you call who's there I am the wind blowing through your hair I am the shadow on the moon at night Filling your dreams the prim rift right This is Halloween This is Halloween Halloween Halloween Halloween Halloween Ha ha
Life's no fun without a good scare.
That's our job, but we're not me.
In our town of Halloween.
In this town, don't we love it now?
Everyone's waiting for the next surprise.
Skeleton Jack might catch you in the back and scream like a banshee.
Make each other out of your skin.
This is Halloween.
Everybody scream.
Would you please make way for a very social guy?
Our man Jack is king of the pumpkin patch.
Hail!
This is Halloween!
Halloween!
Now!
In this town, we call home.
Everyone hails to the pumpkin song.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la
Yeah Yeah Yeah La la la la la la la That's like, I swear to you, I feel like I just know three Halloween songs
And then like I feel like, or Maturian or just from like Nightmare Before Christmas And that's a Christmas movie too like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah someone was like why are you garfield this is found footage of the last recording of doka field before she died from finding satin's field i don't know if you heard like the cough drop bouncing between my teeth while i was trying to sing that uh
Um, I think that was it.
That's like all the karaoke songs that I know that, um, that's Halloween theme.
Other than, I mean, all of them are like, the good ones still are like, yeah, it's like fucking ensemble as well.
Oh, wait, I forgot.
There's this one.
I don't know.
I mean, I would have said, Chalapa, but like, dude, you don't have a karaoke of that, unfortunately.
Uh, you're walking down the hallway.
They're in the corner of your ICM.
Child above.
I don't know.
Wait, is it this?
Oh, they do.
Wait, they do have it in care of fun.
This is the best song ever made.
You're walking in the woods.
There's no one around.
Your phone is dead.
Wait, I gotta be more immersed for this.
There we go.
I think this...
Give me a sec.
You're walking in the woods.
There's no one around.
and your phone is dead out of the corner.
He's following you about 30 feet back on
you.
Shia LaBeouf.
You're looking for your car, but you're all turned around.
He's almost upon you now.
You see, there's blood in his face.
My God, there's blood everywhere.
Running for your life from Shia LaBeouf.
He's brandishing a night in Shia LaBeouf.
Lurking in the shadows.
Hollywood superstar Shia LaBeouf.
Living in the woods.
Shilabove!
Killing for sport!
Eating all the bodies!
Actual cannibal, Shilabove!
Now it's dark, and you seem to have lost him.
But you're hopelessly lost yourself.
Stranded with a murderer, you creep silently through the underbush.
Aha!
In the distance!
A small cottage with a light on!
Hope, you move steadily forward.
But your leg!
Ah!
It's caught in a bear trap!
Climb off your leg!
Limping to the cottage.
Now you're on the doorstep.
Sending aside.
Shilabuff.
Sharpening axe.
If he doesn't hear you enter.
Shilabuff, you're sneaking up behind him.
Strangling superstar Shilabuff.
Fighting for your life with Shilabuff.
Wrestling a knife from Shilabuff.
Stabbing his kidney.
Safe out blast from Shilabuff.
You leap into the dark woods, blood oozing from your stomp leg.
You've beaten Shia LaBeouf.
Wait, he's a dead shy surprise.
There's a gun to your head and death in your eyes.
We can't do just this, too.
Body slam superstar Shia LaBeouf.
Legendary fight with Shia LaBeouf.
Normal choosing knife with Shia LaBeouf.
You try the swinging axe at Shia LaBeouf.
But the blood is draining fast from your stomp leg.
He's dodging every swipe.
He parries to the left.
You counter to the right.
You catch him in the neck.
You're chopping off his head now.
You have just evaporated Shiloh above.
His head topples to the floor.
Expressionless.
You fall to your knees and catch your breath.
You're finally safe from Shiloh above.
Perfect.
Oops.
I forgot the microphone.
What was it called?
There was another one that he did.
Try and remember.
It was like, it was, it was...
Oh my gosh, I don't remember.
I cannot remember.
Alright, if this bot gets marked, I'm sorry.
No, he did another one.
It's also pretty good.
I don't know this song very well.
But I know everyone does.
I mean, I was like, that's your way.
That's Halloween appropriate.
I should never watch Ghostbusters, so I don't know if I can sing this.
Ghostbusters!
There's something strange in your neighborhood.
Who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
There's something weird and it don't look right.
Who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
.
your head, who can you call?
Ghostbusters!
An invisible man sleeping in your bed, who you gonna call?
I'm afraid of the ghost.
Who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
All alone.
Pick up the phone.
And call.
What's the fate of no ghost?
This is four minutes?
I hear a nice girl.
What?
I ain't afraid of no ghost.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
We're gonna call it.
Ghostbusters!
You have, what the fuck?
I don't know those lines.
I just know he goes, Ghostbusters!
It's more?
Let me tell you something.
Busted makes me feel good!
Buna-na-da-da-na-na-na.
I'm afraid no ghost.
No,
no.
Let's just want some more.
I think you better call Ghostbusters.
I'm literally the person that's ghost, Ghostbusters.
Ghostbusters!
Who you gonna call?
Sisters!
Ghostbusters!
I'm the background vocalist for my own karaoke.
Is that it?
Ghostbusters!
It was 40 minutes four minutes, but I swear 80% of the song is just, who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusties!
Guys, if this VOD lives, if this VOD doesn't live, I'm so sorry.
Yes, we're just gonna cut the karaoke portion out.
Yes, I don't know.
I don't know if it's gonna be alive, guys.
Oh, and a monster mash.
I don't remember the monster mash.
Let's see.
And a monster mash.
I don't remember the monster mash.
I think the last time I've ever heard the monster mash was from the Scooby-Doo movie where Shaggy and Scooby babysit like, babysit like a bunch of monster girls.
And they started doing the monster mash.
And I had like a VHS tape of that.
and then I would re-watch that all the time.
And then the DVD came on and then I'd never watched it again.
Ha ha ha ha.
Whoa.
I was working in the lab late one night when my eyes beheld an eerie sight.
When my monsters from this lab began to rise and suddenly to my surprise, he did the mash.
He did the monster mash It was a graveyard smash It caught on in a flash He did the mash My laboratory in the castle east To the master bedroom where the vampires feast The ghouls all came from their humble abodes Get a job from electrodes
They did the monster mash.
It was a graveyard smash.
They did the mash.
It caught on in a flash.
They did the monster mash.
Zombies were having fun.
The party had just begun.
The guests included Wolfman, Dracula, and his son.
The scene was rocking all her digging the sounds.
on chains backed by his banging hounds.
Coffin bangers, we're about to arrive with their vocal group, the Crypt Kicker Five.
They needed a monster mash.
Monster mash.
And it was a graveyard smash.
They played the mash.
It's caught on in flash.
They did the master mash.
Out from his coffin, Drax boasted ring.
Seems he was troubled by just one thing.
He opened the lid and shook his fist and said, whatever happened to the Transylvania twist.
It's now the Monster Mash.
It's now a graveyard smash.
It's got on it on a flash.
It's now the Monster Mash.
Now everything's cool, it's a part of the band.
My Monster Mash is the head of the land.
For you, the living this mash was meant to.
When you get to my door, it's all that Boris sent you.
Then you can monster mash.
And do my graveyard smash.
You'll catch on in the flash.
Then you can monster mash.
Oh, mash good.
Easy, Igor.
boy.
Oh, mash good.
Oh, is this like the Frankenstein singing along?
Easy, Gort.
Mmm.
Mash good.
What the fuck?
I don't even know that was part of the song.
Also, I know of the monster mash from Where Will our mitzvah boys becoming men men becoming wolves that's also why i do the monster mash as he has a 30 rock boys becoming men men becoming wolves wait do they have that do they have that werewolf our mitzvah oh my god if they have werewolf for mitzvah i would be so happy werewolf oh they don't have werewolf or mitzvah if only they have a song called i was a teenage werewolf what the fuck is that werewolf or mitzvah mom spooky scary boys becoming men men becoming wolves that was that was sung by not tracy morgan but um by donald glover which is fucking hilarious like he he did like a tracy uh tracy impression it was sung by donald glover and if you guys were like who's donald glover he's the guy that was that played trojan community and he's also the guy that sang this is america bang bang yeah he was childish gambino yeah yeah yeah and then he also wrote his you know how he wrote a lot of a lot of good songs as childish Gambino he also
wrote where wolf bar mitzvah he peaked he peaked with that like this true masterpiece of his career man is an artist yeah men becoming wolves
all right that's actually all the halloween songs i know i don't know any others i mean if you guys want to throw some out and let me see if i remember them or not wait there's this one i don't know they have this one what is it called it's like is it this one oh my god is this is it this one is this the song that i'm thinking of
God, yes!
Oh my God!
This is a classic.
Our love story could be kind of gory.
More of a...
You remember this song?
Oh my God.
Double clips.
I should need to listen again.
Guys, you slowly walking in the group stalking.
You, you being the only man alive.
I could not resist.
Then All your friends, they try to kill us, but only because they be jealous.
There are lovers deeper than Edward and Bella's.
Oh, if I were a zombie, I'd never eat your brain.
I just want your heart, yeah, I want your heart, I just want your heart, yeah.
If I were a zombie, I'd never eat your brain.
I just want your heart, yeah, I want your heart, I just want your heart.
I hear Rambana, second floor apartment, knocking all the stairs down to save your life from the undead.
Double-barrow shotguns, taking up the slow ones, then you see the passion burning in my eye.
And I keep my hand.
Then all of your friends, they try to kill us, but only because they be jealous that our love is deeper than Edward and Belle.
Oh, if I were a zombie, I'd never eat your brain.
I just want your heart.
Yeah, I want your heart.
Yeah, oh, if I were a zombie, I'd never eat your brain.
I just want your heart.
Yeah, I want your heart.
I just want your heart because I want you.
What is this song?
It's like girl bait.
I respect you too much So that's why I wait until we got married Oh That our happiest days would be spent Picking off all your friends But I see I'd love to see Won't stay buried It's for girls who are like Raw XD Raw means I love you That's what the song is for target audience and damn I listened to that song.
I was the target audience.
Yeah, I want your heart because I want your heart because I want you.
Only in there.
I thought those but that's why I was so surprised that they had this song.
I was like, oh my god.
Wait, they have a key.
I was like, do they have the zombie song?
I was like, that's another Halloween song that I know.
Yeah, I was a raw XD girl.
I was like, Tiki, random.
Oh, isn't that...
I've never played Plants vs.
Zombies, though.
Zombies.
So I know, like, what is it?
Zombies on my lawn?
Is it from there?
You don't...
in memory.
I don't think they have it, though.
Okay, he is not baiting me to feed him again.
What?
Why?
No.
He's so bratty now.
I don't know why.
Can't be because of me.
No, I never played plants versus zombies.
I think, like, I was an angry birds gal.
You know, you're either a plants versus zombie or an angry birds gal.
That was an angry birds gal.
I didn't play plants versus zombie.
I don't know what they're saying.
Halloween songs are out there.
Like, Mother likes... No!
No, he doesn't.
I'm a good person.
I can't... I don't know.
Five Nights at Freddy?
I need, like, I need, like, the robot filter for it, but I don't have that on my Go XLR.
But... I don't know.
It doesn't work the same.
It doesn't feel the same without my robot filter.
We're waiting every night to finally roam and invite newcomers to play with us.
For many years, we've been all the long...
I don't know, that's hard.
Yeah, I need the robot feeling.
I mean, I could do this.
Does this sound more of a nappy?
Does it?
Since that's it, the boss or took our neck away.
Now we're stuck here to decay.
Oh no.
What is that note?
I'll turn it off.
It does sound strange.
Yeah, it's hard to sing without the Robo filter for this.
Because the song is not meant to be singing naturally.
Like even the lead singer.
Let's have friends.
Is this where you want to be?
Like even the lead singer has the Robo filter.
there.
I don't remember how to sing this song.
It's been so long.
We're really quite
surprised to get to see you another night.
You should have looked for another job.
You should have said to this place goodbye.
It's like there's so much more.
Maybe you've been in this place before.
We remember a face like yours.
You seem acquainted with those stories.
Please let us get in.
Don't walk us away.
We're not like what you're thinking.
We're poor little souls who have lost all control and we're forced to take that role.
We've been all alone, stuck in our little since 1987.
Join us, be our friend, or just be stuck in the fence.
After all, you only got five nights at Freddy's.
Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it.
Why do you wanna stay five nights at Freddy's?
Is this where you wanna be?
I just don't get it.
Why do you wanna stay five nights at Freddy's?
So, ah, I didn't take enough breath for that.
Ah,
I didn't take enough breath for that one.
I was just like, fuck it.
Five nights at Freddy's.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I know are nice at Freddy's oh my okay not low-key I actually love has been hotel songs I don't like the show because I think the pacing is fucking terrible um but they have really good songs and I've been obsessed with gravity lately gravity is so good I just haven't heard it yet the guy the girl who sings for it is just so good um yeah like I was I try to watch the episodes of has been And I swear to I can't like it the pacing is so bad for it.
It's just it's just not I don't know this the I don't know maybe I think animation is really nice.
It's just it's just the story is just not the best I love the songs though.
I love the songs.
It's just the pacing for that is so bad Like,
yeah, and the writing, yeah, the writing is meh, but like, you know, it's written by, what's your name?
I don't know how to pronounce your name, and, like, she uses, like, swearing as, like, a crutch, not gonna lie, just like me.
Fuck.
Um, no, like, for season one, I watched, I stopped that episode, too.
just because I was just the writing was not my favorite of like I like anime shows but like the writing was just not my favorite all right what Halloween songs is there just like me I like swearing as my crutch she's just it's just I stare I watch the show and I see myself in and I didn't like it no I can't do thriller I don't have Michael Jackson's voice he's it's like oh my god and it's six minutes i am not doing six minutes i it's also six minutes bro i can't do and like it's he's all like and he has like a fucking 20 minute long intro too and also it's michael jackson i don't think i can i can do the king of pop correctly he did monster mash.
He did the mash.
I did the monster mash.
I don't know.
No.
He did the mash.
I'm
not.
There's not a lot of Halloween songs compared to like Christmas songs now that I think about it.
There's actually not that many.
Let me see.
Halloween and the sun's yeah now that i think about it there's actually not a lot
oh thriller this is Halloween ghostbusters um I don't even know monster mash what the fuck the Serbia by Rihanna what the fuck is that song psycho okay blinding lights by the weekend what the fuck I don't think that's a Halloween song hungry like what a black oh wait i love wait what is it called i wish i like okay i'm just gonna choose one of them what is it called sisters oh oh my gosh what are they called what's the word oh what are their names called i'm trying to remember uh i mean i know this okay i know the title of this one hocus pocus i like hocus pocus songs I like Hocus Pocus.
That's another Halloween song I know.
Into a land of enchantment.
Come little dragons, the times come to play.
Here in my garden of magic.
so slow i remember the original was like a lot faster oh little dragon i'll take me away into a land of enchantment oh little dragon the times come to play here in my My garden of magic.
And in this world, like, I start abducting kids.
And, like, I don't know, killed them, I think.
I didn't watch the movie.
I just listened to the songs.
I just, I assume that's what she did, right?
Yeah, she started abducting kids.
And they're like, I don't know, for a potion, I think.
To, like, murder them?
Anyway, Chagoon's here.
That's...
Are you ready to get murdered?
Yeah, it is Disney.
But, like, Disney back then didn't fucking care.
There was a lot of murder back then.
Back then, Disney was not, like, super anal about murder for some reason.
Oh, this one.
I put a spell on you.
All right.
Oh, they don't have it divided.
Oh, my God.
I guess I'll be all three sisters, guys.
But spell on you.
And now you're mine.
Yet stop the things I do.
I lie.
I do.
I haven't heard this song in 300 years down to the day now the witch is back and there's hell to pay yeah my pacing for this is bad spell on you and now mine I like the song though oh some my name is Donkey bird, what's yours?
I put a spell on you.
And now you're gone, gone, gone.
My whammy's fell on you.
And it was strong, strong, strong.
Your wretched little lies above its curse.
Cause of all the witches working, I'm the worst.
I put a spell on you.
And now you're mine.
If you don't believe, you better get superstitious, ask my sisters.
She's vicious.
I, I, okay, put a spell on you.
A wicked spell.
I put a spell on you.
Sister, I say, on to buy, alpha, maybe, up and die.
I say, into buy, alpha, maybe, up and die.
Koryama Koryama Koryama Hey he ha he say he Bye I love I love what put a spell on you It's such a good sign I just don't remember the I don't remember how the pacing goes in the beginning I say but I know I love the Disney performances of it I don't know like it was apparently called I never watch hocus pocus but I know like it's a cult has a cult following and I like watching the performances that uh like the videos that they do for disneyland during villains night and i'm not a disney adult i just think it's such a good song i say i put a spell on you
i put a spell on you yeah i heard it's a nice movie um but like i know it bombed at the box office when it first came out.
Oh, I love friends on the other side.
Alright, I'll do two more songs.
Because I realize it's almost four hours now.
I did not think I was going to stream this long.
Guys, I was supposed to even though terrorize today.
Oh my God, wait.
I wish I know I was singing this song.
I like this song too.
Well, not... Don't you just Don't you disrespect me, little man?
Don't you derogate or deride.
I know how it's like, you're in my world now, not your world.
And I've got friends on the other side.
That's an echo, gentlemen.
Just a little something we have here in Louisiana, a little parlor trick, don't worry.
Sit down at my table.
Put your minds at ease.
If you relax, it will enable me to do anything I pleased.
I can read your future.
I can change it around.
I'll look deep into your heart and soul.
You do have a soul, don't you, Lawrence?
Make your wildest dream come true.
I got voodoo, I got hoodoo, I got things I even tried.
And I got friends on the other side.
The cars, the cars, the cars will tell.
The past, the present, and the future as well.
The cars, the cars, just take three.
Take a little trip into your future with me.
Now you young man are from across the sea.
You come from two long lines of royalties.
I'm gonna run on myself on my mother's side.
You know, I know I'm a duchess.
You know, it's not high But your funds are low You need to marry a little honey who's got daddy got dough Mom and dad cut you off, huh playboy Now you gotta get hitched bitch and ties you down.
You just wanted me free hop from place to place But freedom takes green
disagree disagree you mean when i look at your future it's a green that i see oh you little man i don't want to waste much time you've been pushed around all your life you've been pushed around by a mother and your sister and your brother too and if you wasn't married you'd pushed around by your wife.
Find your future that you are see.
It's exactly the man you always wanted to be.
Shake my head.
Come on boys.
Won't you shake a poor sinner hand?
Yes.
Are you ready?
Transformation Central Reformation Central Transmortification Central Can you feel it?
You're changing, you're changing, you're changing Alright, I hope you're satisfied But if you ain't, don't blame me You blame my friends on the other side
Yeah.
Anyway.
Anyway, this was a song I wanted to, what was it called?
This was a song that I wish I know how to sing.
But I don't know how to sing this song.
But it's a good song so we're gonna jam it out with someone else singing it for me.
I low-key, I low-key think Monster High is a good show slash franchise.
Down the darkened hallway, everybody turns to look at you.
It's not because you're different, it's just because you're so scary, cool, sinister style.
with a smile, if they're gorgeous.
Drop their gorgeous.
He must fall near creeps, but when I'm with my peeps, you can't ignore us.
This is where the goal kids rule.
Monster, Monster, hi, Monster, Hi, monster, Monster, hi, come on don't be shy.
Monster, hi, but party never.
Monster, monster, hi, monster, high.
Monster, monster, Hi, klim, monster, hi.
Thank you, God, I'm falling apart.
Uh, Dracula is stealing my heart.
Caughty wolves, we make you hallowed moon.
Laguna, you're the finest fish in this lagoon.
Clear the Nile, you're so big gal.
Even though you act so vile.
And do that stone cold style.
Those are my booze, my skill in the crew, I'm a little strange, but so are you.
Don't you wanna be a monster too?
Oh, Ricky just got fabulous.
Everybody wants a piece of you.
I smile.
realistic, most characteristic, most hip and horrific.
A sinister style, mystery with a smile.
You're a drop dead gorgeous.
This gold gives me the crease, but when I'm with my peace, you can't ignore us.
This is where the gold kids run.
Monster, monster hide, monster hide.
Monster, monster hide.
Come on, don't be shy, monster hide.
Monster, Monster High, Monster High, Monster, Monster High Freaky, she can fly Monster High We're student bodies, M-O-N-S-T-E-R Monster, Monster, so bizarre M-O-S-T-E-R Monster, Monster, yes we are Monster, Monster High, Monster High, Monster High Come on,
don't be shy, Monster High The party never Monster, Monster High, Monster High, Monster High Freaky she can fly, Monster High, where student body lies.
How about you?
I love, okay, I love Monster High.
Also love the fairy, what is it called?
Happily Ever After, bro, I was obsessed with that shit.
I watched like all the miniseries and the movies of like Ever After High and Monster High and like the web episodes and stuff.
just so interesting it was so good and then they like and then they made them 3d and then it got less good but i mean it was still all right i guess i still like watched a little bit and then they like they like discontinued ever after high i was so sad um apparently they rebooted monster high the web episode stuff again but at that point i didn't care as much anymore but had i had a I don't know.
It was just the story was so interesting.
And I just really enjoyed the story and the characters.
They were just so interesting because they're like all about being like, you know, they're monsters, but they're pretty fashionable monster.
I don't fucking know.
I just there was just something about it.
They were used to sell dolls and goddamn it worked.
I never owned a single Monster High doll, but so I guess it didn't work that well.
I was never a doll person.
I was a littlest pet shop.
I own a lot of...
The only doll thing I collected was littlest pet shop when I was growing up.
So, it didn't get me.
They didn't get me, but I did enjoy the shows.
Yeah, they're just monster girls, you know?
Yeah, there were some monster boys, but it wasn't as good as the girls.
Anyway, that's like...
Now that's all the Halloween songs I know, I think.
let me double check
I like how it says stranger things theme song that's not even like a fucking karaoke that's like they're even lyrics wait I'm gonna check it's just like how is that like part of the fucking Halloween karaoke oh my okay I was gonna say they did have stranger things on here I'll just be like
I swear I swear to god.
What's new Scooby-Doo.
I'm coming after you I mean there's a rocky horror picture show, but that I don't really the only time I've ever listened to that song I know I know guys is from glee it's that's the only time oh wait there's one we would have we could forget this one because they did a rocky horror picture show special on glee and that's the only time i've ever listened to that song but there's also this one
they're creepy and they're cookie mysterious and spooky they're all together The Adams family Their house is a museum Where people come to see them They really are a scream The Adams family Needs Sweet
Batiste Forget the witch's shawl A broomstick you can crawl on We're gonna pay a call on The Adams family Oh That's how it ends
What the fuck?
It just doubles.
Even the caravan was like, that's it.
It started looping itself.
banana banana banana banana banana i love the adam family i hate wednesday though but i love i okay i say i hate wednesday because it's like but i still watch it because i'm trash and i like trash too i know i should hate it but like it's it's still like there's just something about trash TV shows that gets me like I still watched I didn't watch season two um I but like it's just I but you hate I can hate multiple days you know like you know Wednesday is a bad show but you just can't stop watching it that's what that's me that's that's basically me I know it's a bad show but I can't help it
like I didn't watch season two though.
I don't know.
I don't know if season two gets better or anything, but I didn't want... I didn't know where it's but it's the fact that they made, like, a romance.
Because, like, I'm like, Wednesday doesn't fall in love, bro.
She is a strong independent woman!
Wait.
They don't have a lead vocal.
They don't know how... What the fuck?
I don't know how to sing this song.
It's takes its toy.
Do they have, like, Hello, I would need like vocal assistance for this because I don't remember how this goes.
The only time I've listened to this was on Glee Oh my god, they don't I'm sorry guys.
I don't know how to sing this rock the time warp
I was gonna say if they had like a the if they had the Touch it touch it touch me That's when like shoes new wife or like or his or his mistress starts singing that song and i was like that's fucking weird but okay wait none of them has like the um oh no you guys don't know that song
that's from rocky horror picture show as well oh my god none of them has the vote lead vocal i don't know how to sing the song
It has like, it has like, it gives me the guidance, but I don't know how to sing it.
Goodbye, Rocky Horror Picture Show.
You would think that they would have someone doing guide vocals for this because it's a cult classic.
Yeah, but I don't know how to sing it.
I'll do Scooby-Doo, so I know.
This is the best version.
I sang this in members, but I would say that this version is the best version of Scooby-Doo.
What's this Scooby-Doo?
We're coming after you.
You're gonna solve that mystery.
I'll see you Scooby-Doo.
The trail is back to you.
What's this Scooby-Doo?
We're gonna follow you.
You're gonna solve that mystery.
We see you Scooby-Doo.
We're coming after you.
What's this Scooby-Doo?
Don't look back, you may find another clue.
Scooby snacks, we'll be waiting here for you.
What's a Scooby-Doo?
We're coming after you.
You're gonna solve that mystery.
I see a Scooby-Doo.
The trolley's back to you.
What's a Scooby-Doo?
Na na na na na na na na na na.
Na na na na na na na na na.
Na na na na na na na na na na What's the Scooby Doo?
Yeah, I would say Simple Plan has the best Scooby Doo version of all time I don't like, I think like there's the best one out of all of them honestly Because like what was it?
What was that school?
I think that was also the best show too The best, the song that the show is from opening is from is also the best version of Scooby-Doo they've ever done.
The best animated show that they've ever done.
I don't know if people were like oh what about the Mystery Inc.
one?
And I was like no no no no no.
No no no no no.
I don't remember the show where the Scooby-Doo song Simple Plan was from is the best one.
I don't, yeah.
I know that Mystery Incorporated is good too but like I still think the other one's still better.
Yeah it's literally called What's New Scooby-Doo I know mystery ink was really good because they did a lot of character building and like you know Daphne was an actual character um but no no what's new Scooby-Doo um what's your Scooby-Doo banana na na na na na na na na na na na what's new Scooby-Doo with the other side I would be so happy you know what i looked up i was like did they have teletubbies
if they had teletubbies i would end the karaoke with that i literally i'm in like blast song guys teletubbies my way bonob oh why not what do you mean it's the best song to end it on the little piece wow wow wow
you know i don't know i don't i don't think i could sing this song but i love this song though now we're just doing regular karaoke it's not spooky anymore i'm feeling lonely says i can be All by myself in a charted island in an endless sea.
What makes me happy?
Fills me up with glee.
Those bones in my jaw that don't have a flaw, my shire teeth and me.
My shire teeth that twinkle, just like the stars in space.
My shire teeth that sparkle, add beauty to my face.
My shire teeth that glisten just like a Christmas tree.
You know they'll walk a mile just to see me smile.
Woo!
My Shining Teeth and me.
Yes, they're all so perfect.
So white and pearly.
Brush, gargle, rinse, a couple breath mints.
My Shining Teeth and me.
My Shining Teeth's so awesome.
Just like your favorite song.
My Shining Teeth, I blossom.
So they grow to be real strong.
My Shining Teeth, I love them.
And then they all love me.
Why should I talk to you when I got 32?
Whoa!
My shiny teeth at me.
BOOM!
My shiny teeth at twinkle!
Just like the stars and stars!
My shiny teeth that sparkles add beauty to my face.
My shiny teeth that glisten just like the Christmas tree.
You know they walk a mile just to see and smile.
Whoa, my shiny teeth in me.
My shiny teeth that twinkle just like the stars in space.
My shiny teeth that sparkle add beauty to my face.
My shiny teeth that glistens just like the Christmas tree You know they walk a mile just to see me smile My shiny teeth and me My shiny teeth and me My shiny teeth and me Yeah!
That's right, I'm Garth Skylar now Garth Skylar That's me, yeah that's from, that's my shiny, for those who don't know i know like i repeated that like 20 times but that is my shiny teeth and me um by um from my fairy odd parents from he was like one of the backstreet boys the guy who sang that uh his name is chip skyler oh my god okay i'm gonna have to sing this now and i said oh we'll do two more songs and i did like five All right,
you chipmunks.
What do you sing your song?
I say, yeah, I'm singing now.
Okay, okay, Theodore.
Come on.
Okay, Alvin.
Kiss, miss, kiss, miss, time is there.
Time for joy and time for cheer.
We will go back to our endeavors.
Christmas fairy stars.
What a thing that loops the loop.
Me and mine are her.
We can hide from the rain through Christmas down below.
Thank you, Simon.
Very good feedback.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Alvin.
In that room, star loop.
I don't mind a hoot.
Please Christmas don't be raised.
We can hardly stand no way.
Very good boy.
Let's sing it again.
No, that's enough.
Let's not overdo it.
What do you mean overdo it?
We don't want to sing it again.
Go!
Wait a minute, boys.
Go sing it again.
No.
You did this.
I lost like 30 viewers that seeing that.
So I'm like, no.
I'm out.
I don't even know what it sounded like.
I, you know, I don't even know.
I don't even know what I said.
I just saw a pitch up and I was like, all right, it's time.
They weren't strong enough.
I don't even know what that sounded like.
It's a very, very, I just pitched.
I don't even know how I just pitched it up.
That's all I did.
Today we are calling week one.
week.
Okay, okay, I'll do like two more Halloween songs for real this time.
Don't worry, we're not ending.
We're not ending with Alvin and the Chick-fil-A.
Oh, I love Alvin.
I watched all the live action movie.
Unironically.
I even have like the two of, I have the Chick-Monk soundtrack.
I have the two of the two soundtracks for both of them.
I own the physical copies of both Alvin and Chick-Monks.
One and two.
So, rip away.
I am not ashamed.
I am not ashamed of my love for Alvin and the Chick-Monks.
Yeah, I watched all four of them.
I watched the, what was it?
The first one, the one when they added the ladies, the third one where they, um, where they got shipwrecked, and then the fourth one where they went on a road trip.
Don't worry.
I've seen it all.
There, yes, dude, it's called the road trip.
four people thought there were three because there was chip wrecked um because that's the third movie but there was actually a fourth movie where they went on a road trip called the road chip it was alvin the chick months i forgot what second one was like alvin and like i remember i don't remember what the second movie was called but i remember uh chip wreck and road chip because they were so that was such a good name those were good that's very clever i didn't grow weird because they look like real people because they don't even look like chikmas like in the original cartoons like because they just look like people they look like children um they just you know they just look like children so like i never oh yeah it's called the squeakwell oh yeah the squeakwell that would that's good that's actually good i like that the squeakwell
i'm trying i don't know baby shark two two dude okay like there's baby shark in my fucking caravan but like we're not allowed to sing that because that's when we don't want our body anymore that's i know baby shark is very very protective of their fucking copyright oh i mean like oh no i know what else to say i could i i like the I like the movie.
I like the movie.
Move it.
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Like the movie.
There's that in there.
Yeah, no, Baby Shark has the weirdest fucking copyright shit.
Like, they are very, very protective.
Oh, and make, oh, my God.
Oh, McDonald had a farm is in here.
The duck song.
Do-do-do-do-do.
Bada-bada.
No, I keep singing the song anyway on stream.
I sing the song all the time on stream, it is, but I actually never heard the full song.
I just know that one.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, my dog walked up to the lemon, they said, and said to the man running the sand, hey, bum, bum, bum, got any grapes?
The man said, no, we just sell lemonade, but it's cold and it's fresh and it's all how it and get you a glass.
The duck said, I'll pass.
Then he waddle away, waddle, waddle, till the very next day.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
When a duck walked up to the lemon stand, he said to a man running the stand, hey, bum, bum, bum, got any grapes?
A man said no, like I said yesterday, we just sell lemonade, okay?
Why not give it a try?
The duck said goodbye.
Then he waddle the way, waddle, waddle, then he waddle the way, waddle, waddle, then he waddle the way, waddle, waddle, till the very next day, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, any grapes, the man said, look, this is getting old,
I mean, lemonade's all we've ever sold, but why not give it a go?
Then he waddle away, waddle, waddle, then he waddle the way, waddle, waddle, then he waddle the way, waddle waddle, till the very next day.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, when a duck walked up to the lemonade stand, and he said to the man, running the stand, Hey, bum, bum, bum, gotta eat grapes.
The man said, That's it, if you don't stay away, duck, I'll glue you to a tree and leave you there all day stuck.
So don't get too close.
The duck said, adios.
Then he waddled the way, waddled.
Till the very next day, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum.
The duck walked up to the lemonade stand, And he said to the man, Running the stand, Hey, Bum, Bum, Bum, got any glue?
What?
Got any glue?
No, why would I?
Oh, and one more question for you.
What would he say?
Got any grapes?
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
And a man just stopped, and he started to smile.
He started to laugh.
He laughed for a while.
He said, come on, duck, let's walk to the store.
I'll buy you some grapes, so you won't have to ask any more.
So they walked to the store, and the man bought some grapes.
He gave one to the duck, and the duck said, Hmm, no thanks.
We know what sounds good.
It would make my day.
Do you think the store?
Do you think the store has any lemonade?
Then he watered away, water, water.
Yeah, he was the original rage baiter.
Wada wada And he walked away Wada wada I figured I always sing that song In Sunstream I'm always like Then he walked away Wada wada
And Chasper What?
Chat on Makara I have no idea what that song is Right?
Thank you Super Chat Thank you Thank you Everybody wants to be I got Cause a cat's a kind of cat that knows what it's at.
Wait, what's this?
I actually don't know this song.
Casper the friendly ghost.
I've watched Casper.
I didn't know it had a song.
Bro, I would sing Garfield theme song if it was in here.
How the fuck do you sing the Casper theme song?
Casper the friendly ghost, the friendliest ghost you know.
I don't know this song.
It's like, what the fuck?
I have never heard of this song before.
I'm just here like, Casper, the friendly ghost.
I'm like, the friendly one?
Oh wait, is this a song I know?
I'm going to check.
Is this the one I know?
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, Heroes in the Half-Shift!
Power!
There's some fighting game.
They're a hero, they hatch out, and they're green.
When the evil Shredder attacks, these turtle boys don't cut him no slack.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, Splinter taught them to be Ninja Teens.
He's a radical rat.
Leonardo leaves, Donald Trump does machines.
That's cool but rude.
But Michelangelo is a party dude.
Teenage mutant ninja turtles.
Here's the half-shelves.
I like that.
I got the spooky song to like.
To like.
Let's just sing cartoon songs.
They're the extra spooky.
They're.
They make it.
Oh, guys, guys, I know what I want to sing next.
I know what I want to sing next.
I saw something in here.
And I was like, that's a good song.
And I will end it with this song.
And that's that.
What is this?
They have?
Oh, wait, actually, no, this is not the song I'm ending it with.
But I saw another thing on here.
And I was like, what they have this song?
Look at this.
You might have heard this from your.
short YouTube shorts and tick-tock it's a scare of fun
you're all so lucky you're all so lucky
are here he is like shut the fuck up he wasn't fucking with la bubu I don't understand I don't understand why he didn't why he didn't like that song la bubu la bubu la bubu why is this in care of fun what the fuck I can't believe someone's saying that dude guys oh wait here you go is what i wanted let me see if you can find it uh let me see if they have it first oh they do
all right this is how this is the song i'm ending with
boom Squirrels in my pants.
Tell me what's making you jump like that.
S-I-M-P, squirrels in my pants.
Ain't got no chickens, ain't got no rats.
S to the I to the M to the P. Then maybe you can be moving like me.
Step right over and watch me put it down.
Step right over and watch me put it.
S-I to the M to the P. Who we got back in watering your plants.
S-I-M-P, squirrels in my pants.
How can I qualify for government grants?
Hypnotize me.
Putting me in a trance.
S-I-M-T.
Squirrels in my pants.
Thought I'd forest.
Living in France.
Chance to see the...
Squirrels in my pants.
Step right over and watch me put it.
Ow.
To the...
It's not a zoomersat.
Something in my trousers.
Baby don't need them.
I can't agree.
Everyone's selling my popperies.
the M to the P. Step right over and watch me put it down.
Step right over and watch me put it down.
You know I got it going on.
It's the M to the M to the P. S to the I to the M to the P. If you're proxied MP, you've got a cash advance.
S to the I to the M to the P. If you're losing your hair, get yourself in class.
If you're wrestling a bear and you ain't got a chance.
Old Uncle Freddy's is raging rats.
And about love and about romance.
Got squirrels in my pants.
it's a classic what the do you mean how do you i like how someone was like that's a zoomer song i'm like that is not a zoomer song
yeah it's squirrels in my pants that's what simp originally meant when people were like are you a simp it means do you have do you have squirrels in your pants okay jk i'll do one more that shouldn't be the song we ended with that
I have never, by the way, guys, I know I sang that song, but I have no idea why that song is so popular.
I know people are like, it's like My Little Pony where adults actually love Phineas and Ferb, but I've only watched three episodes of that show.
I know the context.
I know, like, I know the songs.
I've watched the songs and the music videos from the show, the good songs.
And I know, like, I know, Perry the Platypus.
Perry, random Platypus.
Perry the Platypus.
Yeah, it has decent songs.
I just don't know much about it.
Um...
Perry?
Perry the platypus.
I like the little...
The...
What was it?
The Creator's YouTube channel was pretty funny.
I don't know what song to end it on.
Like, do I do a real song?
Or do I do like a...
I do a shit post.
I don't know.
It's so hard sometimes.
Life is so hard.
But I'm...
This, actually, to be fair, the entire karaoke has been my shitpost, I would say.
I was saying something I know how to sing.
It's like, that was the first time I sang.
Squirrels in my pants.
yeah where are goofy goobers yeah no I cannot sing the campfire song I fucking always stumble on that it's so fast oh it's another Irish drinking song I like that song that's a good song I mean to be fair the non-ship post would be disney sounds for me because that's the only thing I fucking listen to all the time I just listen to Disney songs all the time growing up that it's like literally ingrained in my head now
all i like i don't yet to be fair like i listen to disney songs and shitpost songs i mean i do listen to real songs but i can never sing them because they're just way too good for me they're way they're way too good i could never sing it i'm looking through it what the fuck oh natalie's rap i don't know if i can sing this i was actually listening to this recently i love oh and lonely island i fucking love lonely island Natalie Portman.
So Natalie, what's the day in the life of Natalie Portman like?
You really want to know?
Tell us.
I don't sleep, motherfucker, off that yak and that durbin, doing 120, getting head while I'm swerving.
Damn, Natalie, you're a crazy chick.
Yo, shut the fuck up and suck my dick.
I bust into his mouth like gushers, motherfucker.
Roll up on NBC and smack the shit out of Jim Sucker.
What's going on, Natalie?
To drink and fight.
It's a fuck all night.
Don't test me when I'm crazy on that airplane glue.
Put my foot down your throat till you shit in my shoe.
Leave you screaming.
Pay for my dry cleaning.
Fuck your madness.
It's my name that I'm screaming.
I'm sorry, Natalie.
Are we to believe that you continue driving while intoxicated?
I never said I was a role model.
Wait, what about the kids who look up to me?
Do you have a message for them?
All the kids looking up to me can suck my dick.
It's poor man, motherfucker.
Drink till I'm sick.
Slick your throat and pour a nitrous down the hole.
Watch you laugh and cry while I laugh you die.
And all the dudes, you know I'm talking to you.
We love you, Natalie.
I am fuck you too.
It's for Portman.
It's for pussy.
I'll kill your fucking dog for fun so don't push me.
Well, Natalie, I'm surprised all of this from a Harvard graduate.
Well, there's a lot you may not know about me.
Such as?
weed every day.
I cheated every test and snorted on the yay.
I got a dead posse.
You got a bunch of dudes.
I sit right down in your face and take a shit.
Natalie, you're all a badass bitch.
Hell yeah.
I always pay for your dry cleaning when my shit gets in your shoes.
What?
I ask for the drug use.
Well, I can vouch for that.
My dick is scared of you.
Girl!
Okie doke.
Natalie, one final question.
If you could steal a smooch from any guy in Hollywood, who would it...
No more questions.
Okay, I was listening to a song literally yesterday.
I was just like, wait, they have this?
It's a lonely island.
There's a sequel to it.
Seriously from Natalie Portman.
Doki, no.
No.
I was listening to this like yesterday.
You guys know who Natalie Portman is.
He'd be like, what the fuck?
That's why I was like, wait, oh shit, they had this?
I was saying this.
This is a good thing.
I love the island.
Okay, we're not ending with that.
I'm sorry.
I just saw that and I had to.
People are going to clip that.
I'm sorry I had to.
I'm sorry.
I saw this on and out of your clip and out of context.
It just sucked.
I just had to.
I was just like, oh shit, I was listening to this.
I was listening to this like yesterday.
Oh my gosh, that's sushi glory hole.
too why the fuck did they don't have the sequel to natalie's rap come on the sequel is just as good how do we said what to kids wait i hope my bottom be okay i just realized i hope the bottom of you that that song i just realized what the lyrics were i i was just like damn natalie rap's really good and then i was i was like seeing that and i was like
Even if I hope I hope that the pod survives The pod is getting the pod will not be okay
Okay, where are some wholesome songs?
I'll sing a wholesome song guys after that that was not wholesome Don't worry guys.
I'll sing a wholesome song just for you guys
Guys, I should have stopped like an hour ago.
Then the Vaude would have lived.
The Vaude would have lived if I stopped an hour ago.
I'm sorry.
If I kept fighting Sands, everything would have been okay.
If I kept fighting Sands.
No, I can't end it on that.
At least wrap, guys.
I cannot end it on that.
song that was a fucked up song that ended on i only sang because i was like wow i just listened to this yesterday i it like popped up i didn't like actively listen to natalie's rap as of like oh i gotta listen to your fucking rap every week or some um um and then but then it like literally showed it like popped up on my on my playlist when i was listening on my phone and when i you know i put shuffle on and it came up and i was just like oh wait I forgot I have this song on my phone.
La booboo, la booboo, la booboo.
I don't know.
I don't know what song to end it on.
It's hard to find the last song.
I might go do a classic.
I don't know.
What the fuck do I end on?
I'm on a boat.
They don't have my mom.
solo I'm sorry if it did I would sing it I'm solo I'm on solo I'm on solo I'm on solo solo they don't unfortunately if it if they did I would sing it twinkle twinkle little star la sen do we really sing la sen after I said I'm gonna, I'm gonna shit in your mouth.
Like, I said that.
Listen.
That was in the lyrics.
Don't keep please.
She's got, it was a lyric in the, were you guys not listening to the rap?
Like, were you guys not?
It was very explicit.
Oh my god.
Oh, it went very hard.
I was dumbed down to listen.
And that book's not so easy.
Around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, like I'm just just that.
Around the world, around the world, and it's like for five fucking minutes.
Bum-bity-bop-dee-boop.
Nah, my voice isn't high enough for Get Lucky.
that's too hard that goes way too hard for me i'm just a i'm just a i'm just a little girl i'm a little cat actually i'm just a little cat i think yes that funk songs are really they're so high look at this stuff isn't it where did you think
Let's do that.
I like that song.
That's not it.
That's a whole new world.
Yeah, part of you, man.
When was that?
I love that song so much.
Look at the self, isn't it me?
Wouldn't you think my collection's complete?
Wouldn't you think I'm a girl, a girl who has everything?
Okay, wait.
He wants to sing.
I don't know why you're so bad.
What's going on?
Come on.
Take two.
getting a duet this is a solo show he ain't getting a duet this is a the doka field show look at this stuff isn't it neat wouldn't you think my collection's complete wouldn't you think i'm the girl the girl who has everything look at this trove treasures untold How many wonders can one cavern own?
Looking around here, you think?
Sure.
She's got everything.
I've got gadgets and gizmos a plenty.
I've got who sits and what sits galore.
You want theme bombs?
I've got 20.
But who cares?
No big deal.
I want more.
I want to be where the people are I want to see want to see him dancing walking around on those what do you call him oh be flipping your fins you don't get too far legs are required for jumping dancing trolling along down the what's that word again Up where they walk,
up where they run, up where they stay all day in the sun.
Wondering free, wish I could be part of that world.
Where would I give if I could live out of these waters?
What would I pay to spend a day warm on the sand?
understand that they don't reprimand their daughters right young cats sick of swimming ready to stand ready to know what the people know asking my questions and get some answers what's a fire and why does it what's the word burn when's it When I love,
love to explore that shore up above Out of the sea I wish I could be Part of that world
You know, like, the song would be much more meaningful if I wasn't fucking Garfield
It would, it would like, if I wasn't Garfield, it would make, it would like, I don't know, it would be less weird.
They have,
it's, it's like, wow, this is so, wow, so cute.
You're a fucking guy.
Anyway, that's how I like to end it.
Sorry about the second last song.
I just, I don't know.
My intrusive thoughts were like, my rational side was like, you shouldn't sing that on stream.
But then my intrusive thoughts like, do it, you bitch.
You fucking want to do it.
I was like, you're right.
I do want to do it.
You're like, God, say it.
You listened to that song yesterday.
You know you want it to.
Anyway, guys, my Natalie Portman took over.
It's, yeah, yeah.
Anyway, guys.
Alright, guys, let's go back to the, let's go back to the kitchen real quick.
Give me a sec.
I gotta, I gotta poof real quick.
Where am I?
Let me, okay, I'm gonna be, like, standing.
So, give me a sec.
It's gonna look a little weird.
We're gonna be a little under.
immersive real quick guys i should know i can be here wait where am i jk it's not what i want to be but it works okay we're gonna be here yeah there we go i'm no longer tired found footage has ended don't worry i got found that's what it means that's that's what it means i got i got found in the end chat
but i hope you guys enjoyed enjoy doke field babysitting you today maybe you guys are like can't believe doke set up that's not no no no doke doke brick prime doke brick prime didn't say all of that it was you can blame it on doke field it so i hope you guys enjoyed our little halloween special our little halloween special um we'll we'll we'll we'll win we'll win against salons field another time today was not that day i think i would have been still playing i honestly i would have still been playing live we kept going so i hope you guys enjoyed the spooky slash i guess not spooky on karaoke from spooky karaoke,
spooky scary skeleton to like, I don't know, part of your world.
But I know.
Also, I did not fucking practice for that karaoke.
I just fucking went, whatever.
I was just like, whatever.
Let's just wing it.
I just wanted to hang out and have fun.
And that's really it.
there's was a um this was the this was my hangout and have fun day and i'm hanging out and having fun with my dragoons but anyway i'm glad to be able to be dope i'm glad dope me and dokafield can be like you know not hard to portal over now so if i ever want to feel like i want to be dokafield it's now a lot easier than before because before it was for those who remembers you guys might remember how hard it was to get this to work but now now i can just be here let me take a sip real quick um now i can just be here so yeah thank you all for coming i hope you guys had fun i had a lot of fun i don't know i was planning doing rivals after but then i ended up streaming five almost five hours of i don't know two hours of karaoke and then wait two hours of karaoke and then two hours of fighting sands like yeah where is my pipe like i have to add the pipe now like anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you step for
me head to bed guys you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody cheers Wow.
Bye guys.
Bye.